[Music]
[Applause]
no jeans got a huge week jeans big week
firstly I'm filming my special hour this
Saturday June 24th
at the Showbox theater in Seattle if you
would like tickets the link is at
Thousand ranch calm you put in for it
and then they will email you back
also I'm running it one last time if
flappers comedy club in Burbank and the
yoo-hoo room small realm and and that's
it that's all I got on the so in July
night no no when when do you run it he
says I was June 22nd okay yeah eight
o'clock show at yoo-hoo flappers Burbank
July 9th is the palm cast lime can live
at the sperm sperm vine improv in the
where is it it's in sperm vine
California that's a big ol improv there
we did it back in February and now we
are back doing the palm cast for all of
you okay your mom's house so get those
tickets go to Tom Segura calm slashed or
if you scroll to the bottom of the page
it has the podcast states to make sure
you check those out I am going to the
dirty dirty I'm going to be in Richmond
Virginia Virginia Beach Virginia
Greensboro Asheville and Charles come
Charles has come Charleston South
Carolina that's all coming up also
coming to mom Australia please don't
forget Sydney Melbourne Brisbane and
Perth and I launched a huge fall run
Denver Oakland in the Austin San Antonio
there's a whole bunch of them too many
to list
that's all at Tom Segura comm slash tour
and we also hit I almost forgot the palm
cast is going to be in West Palm Beach
breasts balls Beach Florida August 23rd
so
all those go to Tom Segura Tom slashed
or if you want to see Christina P shoot
that special you go mm ranch is that
correct yep
all right there you go what's up gene
your mom's house is supported in part by
bark bucks
do you like how I did that well
bloodsport bucks bark box a monthly
package of four to six natural treats
and super fun toys curated around the
surprise theme for your doggy now as you
know we got two little Lent in our house
adorbs
adorbs beero and bitsy the schnitz and
the thief and every month barkbox picks
the best all-natural treats made in the
USA or Canada and innovative toys to
match a dog's unique needs including
allergies and heavy cheer preferences
and what I love we got in last month's
park box are a little chew toy that
would look like a newspaper and this
hole has been chewing that up like crazy
I like that it's variety yeah but you
got a bunch of little different things
you know I always liked a little squeezy
one ya know and she thinks that that's a
live thing you know it's a melting she's
not bright and they also had these
wonderful fish flavored treats that our
dogs went bonkers for match our dogs and
natural mouth smell thank you for that
here's the good part about bark box if
your dog doesn't like something in the
Box bark box we'll send you something
they'll love for free bark box is a
great way to try a variety of treats and
toys from local and small businesses
that you may not otherwise be able to
find that's very true that's what I
liked best is that it wasn't the stuff
that you can find at the local you know
whatever chain store it was they were
really really cool unique toys and
treats if you love your dog you got to
give this a shot do you love your dog I
love both of my dogs for a free extra
premium toy added to your bark box every
month visit barkbox comm slash mom's
house when you subscribe to a 6 or 12
month plan then select yes please when
asked have a playful pup again that URL
is bark box calm slash mom's house
all right LinkedIn is helpful their
mom's house is also brought to you by
stamps calm I love saving time I love
saving money I love seeing my business
grow I like that a company has found a
way to make all those goals easily
obtainable super reliable stamps calm
brings you all the services of the US
Postal Service right to your fingertips
buy and print official US postage too
for any letter and you package any class
of mail using your own computer and
printer they'll send you a digital scale
automatically calculating exact dosage
stamps comm will even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs no need to lease an expensive
postage meter you are now the post
office in your home we use stamps calm
because it does everything I just told
you it saves us time it saves us money
and it allows us to spend time and money
on things we would otherwise prefer to
be doing I don't want to drive to the
post office I don't want to park I don't
want to wait in line I don't want to
have a long conversation about where I
want something to ship I can do it all
right from my desk right now you can
enjoy Sam's calm with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without a
long-term commitment go to stamps calm
click on the on the microphone at the
top of the homepage and type in mom at
stamps calm enter mom stamps calm never
go to the post office again about that
gene I like it yeah so there you go we
have mr. Aristotle Schaffer also known
as Ari Shaffir is it short for aerosol
or
we throw every throw Scheffer is here
and he joins us a little bit later in
the show but joins us for a good long
time and we had a lot of fun with him it
was great it was really such a quick
time it the time flew and we covered
some really great topics some important
topics just to name a few
area and I finally discussed our mutual
love of [ __ ] to shower
we did some seminal would you rather x'
with him yep
and we caught up with Danny ax see we
saw what they were up to
yeah danger out there apparently they're
out in the open water I didn't know that
it's been a while since we've jumped on
board with the Danny ax so a lot to go
over a lot of fun and again to make this
totally clear I think we've said it
multiple times during the show but Ari
will be on Netflix with a new double
special called double negative
premieres July 18th only on Netflix
Ari Shaffir double negative check it out
okay you should see me when we drive by
a bike store
you should see me when we drive by Oh
bye-bye
[Music]
there you go that's cool it was called
stranger bikes and it's by a sea snake
and Stephen snake and Stephen says I
like that there you go
you know I love it like that stranger
bikes playing off the stranger things
steam I can't wait for that show to come
back it's coming back to when now yes
it's a big uproar right now people are
upset that they didn't renew since 8:00
I couldn't get into that I tried and I
couldn't
did you try I don't I saw the pilot
that's the only thing I saw I couldn't
yeah well they did currently we have
people all over the world right that's
it there's some power superpowers like
one guy can come a lot and then the
other ladies I miss that episode
entirely you didn't know that nope are
they all going to come strike no I think
you're confusing that with something
else
one of them can talk to Hitler no no no
I don't think so I don't think that can
happen
we tried watching last Rob yes did you
do your exercise this weekend while I
was away
yeah did work done how many did you get
through I got through fifty
but that's getting that's progress your
first 50 drugs you to get 300 strokin
yeah and then I possibly have an orgasm
just not ejaculate but having orgasm
happened on the inside how do you I hear
that happens when you when you get
sniped well Rob Rob that you in the
beginning I don't think you b'gok
anything and you get sniped when you get
a vasectomy
oh that you might not I don't think you
make of a gawk at the beginning and then
you make something no dr. Drew was
saying that he doesn't have any juice
that comes out because he had a go
wouldn't know he had yet if your cancer
sorry not it was like to me oh yeah yeah
because vasectomy so see him but not the
potent load yeah yeah no sperm there's
no sperm in it sperm part firms firms
like shrimps yeah firms sperm right yes
people do miss PluralEyes that for
shrimps a lot I hate that measure they
just had an expresso I gave that and I
just came from the library the expresso
one makes you the most upset because I
hear servers and baristas yeah look any
one extra shot of espresso in that yeah
how do you work here
you should know and you've read it on
the menu Overlord the stupid [ __ ] sperms
moon sperms so it was oh so we tried
watching yesterday after porn ends to
hoping to follow yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
hoping to find some gems in there like
we did with the other porno documentary
yeah where she was like she did that
hooker map section segment remember it
was the best to add ah he'll remember
the math go ahead a math land that the
Matt a hooker math was you get like I
don't know five hundred dollars to shoot
a scene right she's going over it she
yes but they offer you to let a guy come
inside of you
yeah an internal surprise an extra
hundred dollars right goes so get an
extra hundred bucks he comes inside then
you know a the morning-after pill the
plan B is only forty dollars only 40
dollars so that's that's sixty bucks are
going to keep in my pocket
if the win-win is which all I gotta do
is let this dude I don't know coming me
on camera so that's needed to mortal
eyes forever okay what's wrong with that
what'd you get sixty bucks huh like I
was telling you a bit if if she had been
like and then for like a guy to finish
inside you know I get another $400
really well you know does that make
sense you're like okay that makes sense
400 ollars will be worth a guy anyone
that you just exchange like what
scumbags
the like that industry is run by they
don't even go like here's 140 so the for
you you get to plan B you get your
family get make a hundred dollars back
they're like
figure it out you're doing whatever you
got it on you maybe you want the kid who
knows yeah
don't you yeah so we were looking for
some gems but apparently these porn
stars they followed are too smart and
they figured out how they were going I
think we got to keep I think we should
finish it because if you notice they
would go do uplifting for me
well they would go they would go
different types of stories like up and
down right so like they would do one
person who was like it was bias back
then and now I'm have you know I'm
retired and and Mary yeah dogs and then
so like that's a kind of a sweeter story
then you go to the guys like I have AIDS
[ __ ] and then they go to the lady who
was like I had a lot of fun doing it and
you know it's crazy blah blah blah so I
think we should I think if we keep
watching we're going to get somewhere
yeah you know maybe fun if it definitely
wasn't hooker hilarious yeah give me
those hard knock stories I know his was
like and his HIV star you Jesus well to
his credit he looks great like he really
seems to maintain his body well and and
he's working out a lot and he seems
happy oh my god god that dude is like so
extra yoked but I think you got to be
juice and right to be on that body
yes especially with an autoimmune
disease definitely my dad was telling me
about that about some of these bodies
you see on people like if you don't know
top dog who's obviously been on the show
a million times he was a competitive
Olympic lifter for years I mean from the
time he was 13 till about 29 or 30 and
he was working out six days a week most
of his workouts were like three hours
plus like these guys were maniacs and he
goes you know I was in great shape I was
a two-time state champion I was ranked
nationally he goes I didn't have a like
the body that you see some of these guys
have right oh wow I'm somebody who's
lifting eight every day and eating steak
every day saying potatoes and every day
this was before supplement creatine
their vitamins no roids he's just like a
workout I ate a steak and I was with it
but it's interesting because you see
you see crazy bodies so especially in
men like super sculpted you know
statuesque bodies and but it's also the
era of like people taking growth hormone
and and and test out you know like sure
access yeah access all writing stuff
because with him like I've seen pictures
of him and he's in his like super
competitive lifting day think looks like
a super fit guy but you don't see like
muscles kind of falling I'm really
defined in the veins and all that you
and your dad are built like brick
[ __ ] is Isaac not a [ __ ] brick
house I was getting is what you do so
that the but you guys are built for that
you're very sturdy and Ellis has that
back to you guys have brought those
shoulders on the back for it we have the
same blueprint my dad yeah in the
direction of working hard at it yeah
right but your genetic I mean you lived
wage we've got with yeah yeah you know
Jim whatever I could I could pursue it
more heat but like we we were talking
about his work out sometime and I was
like [ __ ] that dude
I mean yeah he was competitive not
different I mean I wouldn't a guy I
don't have the desire you and I both
have that lazy gene counteracts any sort
of wanting I forced myself to swim and
do Pilates that I hate yellow Roop this
is the thing that they would lift as
like a team yeah and he goes like if you
left early or skipped any day
the other guys would ride you so hard
about it that you were like [ __ ] that
like they would only go on dates after
you know I mean so if it was like hey
I'll pick you up on Friday and you go
like seven I like Nam 9:30
after I'm done you know what I'm done
this a plan Wow so they were so so yes
that's cool though get in my right now
like in 30 sets you know folks want some
whatnot but it's but your dad is the
type of personality who really likes
structure and Jaclyn and focus and like
having that you know what I found an
unrelated to this really interesting
watching that documentary was like a she
was an old lady now but she did like the
devil and mrs. Jones or whatever that
porno is the old ass
yeah by the way she'll uh [ __ ] way old
huh good old child old huh
she liked the rub rub guy yeah but uh so
but they showed a picture of her and
nude and I was startled by it because
you're like oh yeah that's what human
bodies looked like yeah prior a nice
normal but no and I was beautiful ago
but I forget what normal bodies look
like in print yeah human bodies with
natural breasts that just that that laid
normal and they weren't enormous
quadruple d [ __ ] my Triple D [ __ ] wife
tips I know and platinum blonde yeah
please please please please
looks like it's drawn on like she's
index like she's in shock eyebrow paint
wonder wonder attic is the pot like how
did I know like looking at different
looking women obviously you sure like
you can Riya teammate riot yeah and it's
exciting to see you know like hungry Ted
why did it gets why it went to like as
like that's hot because I don't feel
like that is I don't know which
committee decided that all porn chicks
have to look identical because I mean
like there are men who like hungry or
tits and big shots and different shaped
faces are interesting yeah I was is
different you know all that [ __ ] is
interesting I know what I think in
different hair I think the beginning was
Pamela Anderson honestly I think
sometime around her era is you're right
people went oh the gold standard is
blonde is [ __ ] a huge tits tiny tiny
waist and Barbie it's essentially Barbie
even actually know the porn stars body
is bigger tits than what Barbie had
Barbie was like I see sure these [ __ ]
are quadruple T G eat it's super
comfortable to [ __ ] be like look we
haven't even started what a girl look
how many interesting topics we've
already gotten we were to get out your
fun maybe a hot ticket yeah do it let's
do the show
let's go let's go let's go hey it's your
[ __ ] camera out of here that's none
of your [ __ ] business you talk bite
what response you get the [ __ ] out of
here now get out of here now
don't [ __ ] with me partner you know the
tea our staff is you don't [ __ ] worry
about who I'm with this is who is Randy
don't bring anyone loving to this no
comment about that well your mom's house
[Music]
[ __ ] bite
hey [ __ ] bite you're not part of ta
staff are ya mm-hmm no he's not PR staff
PR t public reactions you know part of
the transsexual Oh adjustments that for
you transgendered what's your pronoun
pronoun sorry offended are you glad yeah
you just assumed my pronoun is sure I
did really assume it what are we going
to see non-binary porn I can't wait to
see all that stuff you only know it's
kind of course that's coming of course
it's going to pronoun I was on Instagram
you know I love Instagram Instagram is
my favorite song isn't it the bet it is
I like photos I like you know looking at
a photo and deciding like that's enough
information for me it's enough I like a
nice caption a photo I'm done I like it
because you really get insight into
people's mental illness it's not you
know one thing I saw the cursory that I
realized is is [ __ ] super weird to me
hmm not weird it's just I go hmm hmm
well I love cars you know I mean I've
always been in love with cars since I
was little boy I liked playing with toy
cars or like car magazines I just love
cars yeah but you'll find somebody that
has you know a photo like I say I found
all this guy in front of his car when I
was beautiful car go to his page and his
page is nothing but him and his cars and
you're like it's just like it's too much
yeah and it's also like this guy defines
himself entirely by what he has that's
interesting
there's that that's so that's how the
guys do it yeah now the girls do the
body the girls do the well what's
interesting about the body thing is that
they take half naked pictures what oh my
god what I got to show you I just got
this text what the bottom read the
bottom ah oh my god
tonight
oh my god what do I do uh I don't know
love to figure this out should we press
pause I think so yeah all right I've got
some exciting show businesses for Tom
which we can't reveal yeah well I mean
yeah I didn't mean to be so dramatic
obviously you know uh you are basically
it's I mean I can say this it's just
like I had an audition
yeah and they they want to see me again
so it's next level so that's awesome and
it's very exciting and will everybody
everybody cross your sphincters for
Tommy Cross crusher behold
hmm it's all good the big excitement
good good week for this grouse a lot
going on yeah what we talking about
before the surprise um fudge
Oh scamper snapples what were we talking
about we're talking about well we're
talking about the porno thing before the
break bodies bodies and then I played
this [ __ ] guy so do you want to know
what that setup was for that yeah why
that guy was flipping out yeah so
apparently there was this uh this is a
cow tell you what it the thing said here
is that the guy there was an incident
occurred at the International Longshore
warehouse Union in Longview Washington
and reporters were there to ask about a
hostage situation that happened weeks
prior so six guards were held hostage
for a couple hours after 500 or more
longshoremen broke down gates and
smashed windows in the guard shack and
this longshoreman is in no mood to
answer these questions so in other words
this is something that's been like in
the news and this news reporter is just
like hey I want to ask again you know or
ask more about the incident that
happened I think calls macaque bite
which is really funny I've never heard
that one before it is amazing talk bites
that's great well I love it you had that
isolated already you knew that was a
winner
Yeah right yeah so a shark bite this is
how the whole thing unfolds this is the
guy showing up the news guy going like
like oh hi I'm with the Ohio view and
just wanted to know if there was anyone
here want to talk to us about the
situation from haha tell you how the
[ __ ] is a longshoreman around here
oh that's the gentleman who gets more
upset man I guess you see that the
cameraman one of them starts filming
something that's printed out your
[ __ ] camera here
oh that's none of your [ __ ] business
you talk bite less you are trespassing
it the [ __ ] out of here now
okay get it all so don't [ __ ] with me
partner you know the PR staff are you I
like that guy maintain a sense of humor
yeah our stuff are you oh yeah I also
think it's funny that the guy goes
unless you want trespassing like not if
you want to be charged with trespassing
hmm like unless you want robbery right
he just he missed some conjugated yeah
well yeah isn't her stress as well
alright that's understandable I think he
keeps saying it you want trespassing
like you want something to drink
listen trespassing with you [ __ ] out
here that's none of your [ __ ]
business you [ __ ]
there's no I trespassing did I hear
right
maybe drunk we want your [ __ ] camera
broke you [ __ ] I just wanted to
hear yours I said by now or you're going
to get trespassing you know you're going
to get trespassing you're going to get
charged with treasure our each other
right or you you know normally I'm going
to I'm going to say you're trespassing
or you again you are trust but you're
gonna get trespassing is this it you're
going to get it you're going to get are
going to give it to them the trespassing
you're going to give you a shot of
trespassing for shrimps yeah the shrimps
and the expressos
all the shrimp's the sperms and the
expresses are going to get you guys
nothing and the liberry liberry you guys
have a library here doing a paper on
shrimp and we're leaving you are the
[ __ ] sit there you know what you
dumb mother
[ __ ] you like your [ __ ] glasses
don't [ __ ] threaten me you son of a
[ __ ] where'd my friend get the [ __ ] out
of this parking lot right baby leaf
likes to go I mean okay sorry fellas get
out of here now give it why is this guy
[ __ ] with him I like the UH he has a
great disposition though the camera yeah
at least he was like I was doing this
man yeah he's done this a 500 times yeah
he's seen people lose their mom don't
you feel like I don't you don't get to
hear people yell like this anymore
you know you don't really get to see it
[ __ ] bites and stuff I feel like I
haven't seen people freak out like this
in a minute yeah I miss it
we just pulled these all the time you're
right that's exciting to me
me too if I like seeing people get upset
like that yeah yeah especially funny you
know this guy's he's upset because there
is a buildup of horn blasting this but
you don't get to see in other words when
someone loses their mind it's not over
something reasonable right it's because
something builds up over time these guys
have been asking questions for six weeks
it's the original trigger yes and he's
mad I do not have this guy he's mad at
the second
yeah the first verse nine hundred
reporters okay yeah this is pretentious
Oh funny
this is the exit I'm not going to touch
that [ __ ] I thought the cult
talked to him in a heartbeat I'm good
bye get out of [ __ ] parking [ __ ] you
you [ __ ]
that's my name [ __ ] you - [ __ ]
yeah yeah I did get him down that's his
name [ __ ] you that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's my name missus [ __ ] yeah we got
to get more angry clips again I forgot
how fun these are and if we could go
around the room and everybody just say
your name you you [ __ ]
all right hi buggy you gauger
[ __ ] bites kind of fight and I miss the
racist ones remember and he liked you
buckets back sorry hahaha screaming over
the fence that was a good one was grew
and I wonder if no suck my [ __ ] that
was good we've been a while that guy was
uh our kiss my [ __ ] yeah I suck my
[ __ ] that well
[Laughter]
[Music]
mother he's longshoremen I wouldn't [ __ ]
with these guys well you know are you
guys do real worry oh we're a and a real
real [ __ ] man well our old landlord
one of our past landlords was a
longshoreman and he was not he was a
very gentle sweet guy but he would tell
stories of his a co-worker's being
gnarly dudes yeah my real gnarly real
gnarly where I worser
[ __ ] just got white wash man I was at
the aeropuerto yesterday bright and
early and I was listening to people talk
on their phones and the rage inside of
me is kind of like that like the [ __ ]
bite rage where you're like what are you
doing [ __ ] you know especially in
this era people feel okay about watching
videos on their phone at full volume in
public like who's and nobody's
correcting this behavior but the phone
conversations insidious because you're
on the receiving end of one side of a
conversation
yeah and I think when it's way worse er
is when it's in a foreign language yeah
and now I don't even understand what the
[ __ ] you're saying and your language
sounds horrible to me and is it I think
the worst language I don't know what he
was I have been Vietnamese only because
they don't have volume control no no my
god it's so loud it's so do you know
that you're in public yeah why are you
[ __ ] it's it's and yelling in your
language listen we spoke Hungarian
growing up in my house between hell yeah
this has speakerphone feedback what we
didn't do in public is speak Hungarian
because it's rude and it excludes people
yeah you know what I mean you think
[ __ ] English we were in public
yeah the the speaking in another
language in public because you really
have a secret that you're excluding yeah
yes it's disrespectful to the you know I
see this [ __ ] to make me oh no you got
your life okay it's your life in front
of them to like top it right here right
now stop
yeah go on at the airport yeah stop it
yeah mm-hmm
yeah I know and you're like do you
serious like no one in this whole [ __ ]
know and it's never about you know it's
not it's not about who won the Nobel
Prize or you know quantum theory it's
always like we're going to meet you down
at the baggage claim all right okay well
Susan gonna bring cake yeah she's going
to bring the cake like what are you
doing
it's total like it is that some people
have total disregard for the world
around them you know for other people
Livius I don't even know if the but I
think some of it is conscious I think it
is conscious like they say what they
want you to hear what they're talking
about sometimes I feel like it's uh
something you know it's it's like yeah
you're standing there and you're like ah
yep interesting none of us are sitting
here minding our own business that's the
thing that stands out is that everyone
literally everyone else in those
situations is considerate everyone else
that's why that person stands out you're
the only one the only one Jen doesn't
care dickbag so now I what's your least
favorite language though let's get into
that I'm going to go with I don't like
Russian I have a bias so we all have
biases today I don't like Russian
because culturally that's my tribe ish
they're my cousins yeah
so that hard sounding Eastern Bloc [ __ ]
like I my shoulders go up around their
ears and never said by the way I hate it
no connection doesn't sound good to me I
don't address it as [ __ ] yeah
motion it will only actually be really
good oh yeah I like hearing I stop if I
had to pick like I don't mind hearing
the Romance languages it just sounds so
pretty yeah I mean Portuguese Spain come
on let the yeah those are all like when
do you get to hear Portuguese and pile
them doing that but I'm saying like it's
not but when you hear like homicide I'm
Alan to the Hamazon scoffing at me
hobbits
no and any language that uh anyway
Israeli they do that as 5c I go back to
your [ __ ] country not that not it's
not it's irregardless its regardless I'm
saying yeah I don't give a sh I'm not
talking specific culture don't care
that's a sound angle your awful language
yeah influence bothers Nigerian doesn't
sound beautiful I'm not all 10min Arling
no nice that's not nice
it's a terrible yeah but uh but I need
to yes anything
I'll throw in yeah that somebody partly
naturally speaking English like that is
that's it why works it's awful awful
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna get method at
the market there's no onions and then
you're like Jesus dude it's worse that
you can understand it cuz you're like
your conversations so dumb so dumb
yeah so boring people just repeat the
same things to each other over and over
and some it is there's a split there are
people that are oblivious because you
can look at someone [ __ ] are you doing
here like what I don't know and then
there's people that it's a what it is
it's it's a an attempt to show power
yeah because what you're saying is like
yes a moment where I can I'm going to
talk loudly yes in this I'm dominating
the space with my voice you [ __ ]
have to hear what I'm talking about yeah
one time you and I were at a hotel we're
coming out of a nice restaurant and
there was a guy on his speakerphone I'm
a few remember it but we were getting a
valet waiting for the valet and full
full volume like I kind of went with the
blah blah blah blah like sounding like
Ivory Coast's something in a soul I mean
actually I'll enjoyed him because I like
that accent yeah but it was just who's
so loud yeah it's sowed it's just soda
but when you're tired and you're in the
airport you're like I don't want to I
want to hear your [ __ ] I don't want
to hear you bro
I agree a lot of basically I don't want
to hear your conversation
yeah area'd or your video or the music
the worst one time I was third out of
their mind sitting next to a girl
watching Korean soap operas here's how
Christ loud some people are is I'm on a
plane a week ago and a kid
as his iPad or whatever or some toy
beautiful blue and I'm like hey I look
over and then his parent was like I
don't forget that one
like I was helping them yeah you're like
why'd you tell your kid to turn that
down or just give him headphones so
hence on the rest of us don't have to
hear pppppp
its obnoxious you are obnoxious one time
I was on a plane and a guy was watching
his movie but he had his earbuds in but
the volume was pumping out full full
volume and it was a late night flight
and I am eyeballing him eyeballing and
finally I go excuse me get could you
listen to that on your earphones and he
goes all I thought I was I'm so sorry
and then he plugged it in that was a 1 I
did actually see a person last week do
the same thing right I think correct
thing what happened was a couple was
sitting next to each other and then our
war started oh and you can hear it in
the cabin like dun dun dun time and I
see them going out with the headphone
they're like and then and then all
sudden the guy yeah
we're not plugged in huh he said yeah
you know he plugged it in but that was
funny
different right like he's trying to
trying to be a civilized human people
are [ __ ] psychos though it's it
really is to the advent of the the
cellular phone yeah it's the iPhone
etiquette we really haven't we haven't
figured out yet what proper etiquette is
for the phone yeah I think that'll be
hopefully in the next few years people
go alright at dinner it shouldn't be on
the [ __ ] table yeah there should be
an iPhone etiquette school or just
societal norms that we should all adhere
to you from now on
agreed are you reading anything now by
the way no boy I'm not going to answer
that that's a setup before is it or no
sure of course it is know what isn't I'm
reading a book right now read notice
what is it read notice there's a lot of
pictures in there yeah
thank you I'm just reading it
interesting uh-huh what's that about
it's about this guy who is his
grandfather started the Communist Party
oh and then he went on it's a Russian
basically real-life thriller so it's my
enemy
basically mm-hmm yeah but I feel about
directions so I'm in the part right now
where he's um is basically introducing
how he came to work he's a businessman
but in Eastern Europe oh very cool so I
didn't know you were interested in that
you should talk to my dad about that he
loves communist stuff yeah so but you're
not reading anything right now
of course I'm I read stuff all the time
but what are you reading right now
ah it's called the something of the
gifted child the called the something of
the gifted child yeah I read a child
psychology book so I don't [ __ ] of our
kid drama of the gifted child this lady
has a review of that right here okay
here we go
reading it oh [ __ ] she's not even
talking yet oh that was my mistake okay
here we go it's reading the book you
have footage of me reading yeah you know
I read Kindles I don't read it pretty
good review right um is that what the
dream to get the child that's the same
thing do we get fart mr. Kham I think we
did last week yeah I think we need to
start doing something with it I'm
surprised nobody had fart mistress I
know I'm really do you really quit
although it just goes to show that the
women doing the fart videos aren't that
creative and that I can really put a
dent in that industry why don't you at
least sell that to somebody you know
fart mistress I mean to a real fart
mistress I would love to hey anyone out
there want fart mistress this one owns
that I'll sell it to you for a
reasonable price
I mean wrong poof
Wow that's her fart so they're really
good one really crazy that's almost a
stripper that's how my mother spoke
English when she first got to the
century yeah yeah like we call a fan of
monster I remember that Oh monster yeah
she's like a monster because she didn't
know a fan big monsters make noise with
his lady said that her ass is like a
monsters pre means kind of accurate now
didn't you have quite a brown day I'm so
glad you brought that up you may want to
hit the all aboard Brown taco I would
get in okay all right I didn't know that
was coming on next drop round talk
anyway horn so I went to man Francisco
this weekend thank you everybody that
came out to my shows they were super fun
it was really great I had a lot of fun
met a lot of mommies and so anyways on a
Saturday I go have Thai food by my hotel
on the Embarcadero there and I don't eat
[ __ ] honky food you know I'm saying
when I want flavor I get some goddamn
flavor especially San Francisco I mean
you've so many great choices in San
Francisco they had to like eat real
offense yeah I love the food there so I
go to this Thai place i order my pan and
curry and I was like you make that [ __ ]
spicy and don't make it [ __ ] white
girl spicy like I want legit heat on
that [ __ ] well I actually have a bit in
my act right now about that seriously
yes seriously yeah yeah I'll tell you
about it because I ordered that way at
Korean barbecue so much no no I demand
that they give me spicy so I don't choke
not a bit of it okay any whoodles I
order it and I ask for spicy and they
bring it out and I'm like oh [ __ ] like
they really it was too much but I
couldn't send it back because I demanded
it you know what I mean so I had to eat
the dish anyways and push through wines
it was hot as [ __ ] dude like they they
didn't hold back on me at all so like I
have to do this like I can't have to
save face so I eat it
forget about it I'm fine and then
Showtime rolls around and the farts
begin and I had forgotten what I had
eaten earlier I was like why these farts
here you know when you do that where you
kind of are like I'm farting but I'm not
sure why and then it occurred to me I
had that Thai food and it was like
mystery solved so I sit down to meg
Brown and I'm having so many pain it's
so much pain because if farts are really
violent like hard farts and I [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] and it's show
time now I'm getting I'm getting text
messages from the club like hey the
shows at 7:30 you know that part yeah
yeah and I'm in my show outfit like
tights dress and I'm like I'm [ __ ]
and it's bad and it's like a multi wiper
and I don't have time to go [ __ ] the
shower because it's show time like I say
are connected I just have to keep rub
rub rub wipe wipe wipe wipe
Neverending wipe there's I've leaky but
there's so much toilet paper in the bowl
there's so much Brown in the bowl it was
so painful and then so I flush and
Michael went down and then the water
rises you dude
and it starts to spill a little little
little amen miraculously it slowly goes
back down so it goes under when you told
me that you was turds on the ground like
your eye and reminded me yes Jackson go
that's right
that's where towards about the comedy
zone and that's where I had turns on the
ground and I had to tell the hotel staff
but they were turds on yeah
the toilet yeah what comes on around and
everywhere bro cool thing on him what
classic dance my Brown my jam right on
the ground yeah yeah I got Tipler made
that it was really good so I got really
close to turds on the ground but no
turrets on the ground in San Francisco
but it was close dude sir it was bad and
I like I said it was just like a leaky
but situation all night I kept the white
bang was terrible yeah do you get that -
I forget what where you doing
never-ending wiper like you just keep
wiping all the whole sex it's so
upsetting
you know that brings up this actually
came in you brought this up right now
isn't dead look this email came in swear
to God don't read it
how do blind people know to stop waving
hey Hitler's I've been a big fan show
since mommy Tina was in fart NICs a few
months ago I've been binge listening 40
plus hours a week horny prize something
every second of it I'm not all the way
through but I've always wanted to know
one thing I believe you're the people
who help me find out how do blind people
know when to get up why they don't
how have we gone this long without
knowing this age-old questions thank you
for everything you do look forward to
next time you are in fart Nicks
oh god this is funniest thing we've
never discussed I feel like we may have
discussed it feels familiar I really do
think we've discussed this I think it's
been a long time
how do you say no - long time they wipe
a bunch yeah and then they do a bare
hand wipe and they smell oh wait I know
what they have a dog
do it again seeing-eye dog no no it's a
reasonable question I think see the dog
sniffs your be home since brown I think
you know I think you just get a sense of
it just like a seal because you're so
now you're so tied to your vision
helping your senses eventually like I
think what happens it becomes intuitive
and they just go I'm done now that's a
good theory well if you're blind I guess
have someone write in for us for you or
you could write in how do they do it
they do get it you don't think rice
either they don't type an email sure
they do and they have Braille keyboards
all right oh yeah okay so use your
Braille keyboard yeah and like let us
know let us know how you white got all
these mysteries and tell us about the
learning curve tell us about bad you
know times you guessed wrong don't just
be like yeah of course I know how to do
it tell us give us a little insight yeah
we're down no no these things see this
is so good this is so important the work
we're doing on your mom's house like
number one I have two for tartar people
knew their [ __ ] and now we're going
to find out if blind people know how
they're done wiping it's pretty really
we're really helping Society we are
helping a lot we haven't yet mentioned
that pretty soon we're going to be
joined by a guest today mr. Aristotle
Shaffer is coming in is it really short
for Aristotle no not his name definitely
not no no no I saw wasn't Jewish no no
Greek yes a Greek name soon I know that
I feel like have more thoughts on this
blind wiping situation though yeah okay
give any more opinions on you can't stop
thinking about it
I feel like that's a wild okay oh here's
what I was going to say because
sometimes Browns are misleading like the
other week I had what I thought would be
a disastrous cleanup you know like it
was hot and I was like oh this is going
to be a nightmare
and I went to wipin the paper was
totally clean yeah so it's like it's not
it's just not a sure a science you know
yeah
who are you texting arey what's he doing
just letting him know to be on time I
don't know I hate when people are late
me too oh my god I just okay you know I
thought was funny and man friend disco
the women we're talking about because
when I lived there in the 90s it was
hard to find a boyfriend because all the
dudes are gay and now now they're not
now they're not all gay now they're all
nerds yeah I hear because of the tech
industry moving up there that there's a
lot more straight guys but that they're
all socially not adept no they're all
dorks big old dorks yeah the whole tech
industry has moved into that area it's
completely changing this also priced out
basically the whole city oh yeah it's
terrible it must be it was hard when I
was living there now it's got to be
whitewash I'm gonna ever want to move to
another city though yeah nothing yeah
but then I go not LA like I just
remember it's not LA right and then I go
back here don't you ever want to live in
a city city again though or no now the
kid I think it's just here where you rid
of them no here's a part about SF is
that just getting groceries yeah you
don't have a car there because it's so
hard to have a car there's no parking
you still want to live on the ocean
though right ocean least you want to go
beach bar 100% you love marine ki I live
in Marin Marin County yeah across the
the Golden Gate Bridge there are here in
LA County you live anywhere beach the
beach side anywhere Mountain marabou
yeah palisade Palisades I not advantage
of Santa Monica
mod - Santino Redondo Venus Manhattan's
for Denali Manhattan manzil - bro E
sometimes for me it bros down Hermosa is
actually the mo bro that's too brilliant
for life yeah I mean you're the [ __ ]
thing bro
yeah but now I like more seclusion I
don't like as many people at Alice
Verdes yeah I love how her day so far
those right now there is no art Oxnard's
too far north
I know the most desirable places are the
ones here and they're so expensive I
know can I tell you where I want us to
retire though we're Maui Maui we're all
like the the nut bet like the Wayne
Dyer's the Doreen Virtue is all these
nut bags that I like
yeah like where all the meditation
retreats are like with Rob - I've never
been to Maui I've never been there
either but I feel like you and I would
really enjoy it bro down I think you
know we really dig Hawaii is like a
retirement I was only my tellin ie yeah
that was crazy fun [ __ ] yeah it was but
I wouldn't live there because there's
only like 3,000 people on that I know I
don't want to live on a too small but
now we got that now we've got it going
on it's pretty excited like you eat
snack adamian nuts every day because
they're there that's that is where they
come from out of the ground they're
there you just walk around and there's
macadamia nut everyone apples people
just go join a glass of pineapple and
they just give you a pineapple that's
right guy you're so smart so smart can
we talk about our dad day yeah and my
Smurf day yesterday yesterday you Sir
Paul McCartney yep my niece Grayson yep
some other kid was it Bella Rossellini
all had birthdays yeah yeah Sir Paul
McCartney that's what he likes me to
call him and Sir Paul and I spent the
morning stuck on a plane I woke up I
slept for three hours is fun and but you
got me this gorgeous ring yeah really
outstanding going to wear it on my
special today today job right you did a
wonderful job you don't know when you
buy jewelry for someone you like did I
do well I don't know until they actually
could tell by the reaction you were like
what you know why because I'm so Eastern
Bloc that I immediately think how much
did you pay for this I don't deserve
this I don't want to wear something
expensive well I get a better of cars or
LS is college yeah I'm glad we spent it
wisely
yeah well I get I you know him to go to
Yale for four years or do you want a
ring until I decided on I know I just
get weird about jewel jewelry it's a
nice ring jewelry that's how you say it
not jewellery you know jewelry
it was for him won in a contest you did
eggs you get this yeah shooting hoops ah
they're lucky jisu well then so you got
me the super nice ring and you got me
some PJs
I did good laugh you're always like
talking about PJs and you
put your PJs on at nighttime camera I'm
not really a PJ guy no I like boxers and
I've tried buying you them about a year
is one of those things do you ever have
things where you go you imagine you want
to be that thing hit injury you know I
mean like yeah
I'm the same way with robes basically
yeah I see some wearing a robe I'm like
I want that robe
yeah and then I get a robe and I use it
twice I know how I lose it I forget
where it is my house so PJ's I see
someone in it like in a catalog wearing
their peden like huh it looks so
comfortable I like sleeping in boxers I
feel about high heels like I'll buy a
pair I wear them once I'm licensed now
Yeah right
the exception is a page eyes thing is
sometimes they make like sleep shorts or
they're real loose baggy the deck shorts
or yeah yeah I like those to sleep in
yeah but I don't like an actual pajama
ensemble you know I don't wear it that's
a little corny for guys some guys are
into it yeah those guys are I'm not
binary word for those magic sure they're
definitely challenging the
intersectional narratives if you know
what I mean I read that to say that I'm
hipster cookies it's just like the gays
yes somebody this orange is the new
black actress is non-binary and somebody
real no no yeah she really is out and
she's good
really hey hi how are you what's your
name once you pronoun you're gonna die
can I read you what she wrote today [ __ ]
her name is a Asia Kate Dylan she's one
of the white girl white supremacist
characters over your name again
Asia ASI a as a Kate Dylan okay and she
plays one of the like I said one of the
white supremacist girls on orange is the
new black so she wrote I think people
received my message of being non-binary
and feeling generally pretty and she's a
great actress
I received my message of being
non-binary and viewing gender identity
as a spectrum better because I'm white
was assigned female at birth
and on a super popular television show
Asia answers honestly my friends who are
assigned male at Birth people of color
particularly those who identifies FEM
have an incredibly hard time they're
ostracized and there are very few safe
spaces for them I'm grateful for my
visibility
the conversations that are happening out
and I just I like the comment so someone
Thank You Asia for complicating the
narrative and keeping it intersectional
I don't know that many knew that I loved
it oh wait okay so she's on this new
show she's a new non-binary are billions
on billions yeah she's on she's calling
her as she and we don't know about her
preferred pronoun but you said her again
to [ __ ] but this person is on both shows
yes on billions and black oh yeah sure
kaylynn it they are darling sorry
they're killing it this other person
writes there's also living in a country
where the language doesn't gender
neutral pronouns so you have to invent
them and that makes it harder for people
to understand all right so what else you
got another things going on anything
happening I don't know why I makes me
laugh so hard that's lying no God love
them the God helped these people
remember that kid he's just Christ oh he
kisses remember you wanted me to bring
back poopie kisses yeah I made a note of
it cuz I guess yeah you said to me the
other day what we got to bring back
poopie kiss that's a nice way to spin so
you're farting yeah you're farting mmm
boopie goes the poopie kiss for your
face I feel like I need to call airy
colors uh-uh uh-uh no let me see because
he doesn't understand well he doesn't
like text like a normal person he has
like a red phone yeah he's so weird yeah
super annoying huh yes I was joking with
me right he's little in here oh he's
here let's stop for a second let's go
get him let's challenge for all right
yeah we had to we had to but we mention
it earlier but it's official it's now a
thing it's here
our guest has arrived you Jew
[ __ ] you
Aristotle Schaffer so well done re re is
that his mic so you're not my son I'm
sorry sorry hold on hold on hold on hold
on give me a second give me a second um
wait a minute no no how about now yeah
work oh yeah kidding on yourself that's
beautiful thank you no we got it work so
is Ari Hebrew for like can I get a
discount what does that actually mean
what is it actually I hope a blogger is
reading this just go to power I will no
blogger ever defend the Jews thank you
yeah what is very short fort open I'm
sorry it is for our yeah our re al ly ah
who are ya it means REI means a lion you
dope boy a lion
Yeah right out of my hair way more
resemblance yeah I want your medal to
have crazy hair
Yeah right it was great great hair I
remember that see people now with that
bushy [ __ ] you know yeah oh my god damn
yeah what's your middle name David in
English and in Hebrew Ari yes we are
warrior but nothing who are you David
you ask any Jew if their name is not
David if you're like what's your middle
name
just guess David yeah and by the way sir
this always makes me crazy when people
are as guests on podcast including when
I've been guests on podcast yeah and
it's like hey I have something and then
we don't address it forever
we also I think at least once right out
of the gate let's mention that on July 9
18 18 18
Ari Shaffir has a memory Netflix special
mmm
set it called I'll take those two
pennies and it's coming out it's double
special but actually what I know that
would be a good name for the special
I'll take those two pennies it's develop
special would actually work I didn't
think it is a double special about it
does it work like the way Chappelle's
does where it's like a collection and
like
yeah those are like I don't know why
they did it like that they're unrelated
completely but that is like that yours
is actually two separate things we'll
play yeah yeah wow do you know that's
incredible yeah I really envisioned it
that way that's not too sure but I
really don't get to finish a special
yeah start number two start over to take
a break
unreal men and they also understand so
you'll film a year apart or simultaneous
I feel I'm summit it so I did at cap
city and uh I changed clothing I
finished it thank you good night and
then they clapped and I was like hey
don't go anywhere I forgot like a
shitload left and then I change clothes
on stage he change the standard off
change the set up we left because I
wanted to have a similar look so I
change it to like the lighting so it's
like distressed wood background and I
change the backlighting and the
foreground lighting I flipped them for
the second one and I just wanna close
interesting a little different I know
but like while you tell them the kind of
the concepts Hospit cebause children my
feelings of it's or you guys are kids
cute but yeah for me yeah right we
figured that out yeah it's not exactly
an inspiration why would you let me
touch them no germs or man I don't like
to encourage stranger strange men's
going natural good boundary in other
words yeah some kids I was age somebody
goes like hey like that and they run up
and hug them I discourage that LRA our
kid doesn't distrust people oh yeah yeah
our kids like so Mac are you looking for
me - yeah right yes I as you know have
contacts at Netflix and I reached out
and was able to obtain a clip oh well
yeah so here's a little today said it
had a big juice at the western wall no
no it's not okay I'm [ __ ] doing that
I [ __ ] know it
[Laughter]
this is not even Orthodox Barmes mine is
a woman doing it I'm allowed in my
operating terrible now while you know
more about your upbringing later the
children that not having care your
feelings about children is one and then
what's the other thing is about
adulthood so it's just and I give it up
for kids a little bit I understand small
parts of them but then the other side is
like a life we really just can't have if
you have like a wife and kids
yeah what can I give you a perfect
example yeah that like it just shows you
kind of different thoughts yeah you I'm
going to New York yeah and you're like
why aren't you staying for like a few
days yeah right and it's the it's a
normal thought for a single guy that
doesn't have a family
New York City I'd like any guy with the
family would be like what do time yeah
why would I stay there for a few days I
actually lived most of my life - you
said it once where it's like ah man I
wish I could - I think was I moved to
New York like I wish I could do that
like why don't you I'm married can do
and I was like oh yeah yeah I mean I
wish I could do in the sense it's like I
go which I could [ __ ] go parasailing
tomorrow - right like it's an enjoyable
kind of like oh that's cool you get to
but I mean I'm not going to do that yeah
you know what there's you know it's
funny when I think about Ellis there's
only a couple of real things I don't
like about having a kid like and this is
so stupid but I don't like not sleeping
as much as we used to or sleeping in
that part of motherhood is the only
thing that really about number one I
covered that in a special
yeah that's hired miss that all you guys
that part but I mean then you wait
against through you know a thing called
ambivalence where you're able to
simultaneously have contradictory
feelings I learned about the sincerity
not everything is black and white right
I didn't know that was until I had a kid
right or not and most people are not
black and white we tried to make
everybody but that guy sucks he's great
lady don't forget charity yeah but it
killed some boys like I know what the
charity still work of course yeah as
most people are complicated really it's
all but I also want to go to Fiji and
that we're going to have to put off
right and that's something we can
literally do
why don't you ro and I'm currently I'm
not telling how to parent your kid like
why don't you leave a bunch of food in a
bowl and then just like
that's a good point cover up the sockets
with a little dimes over already
teaching resilient self-sufficiency now
your upbringing you are or the dog shoes
we know now did your mom wear a wig like
is it that worth about yeah yeah mister
wears away all the time my mom would
generally wear like a hat except like
High Holidays I'm not sure where we're
gonna have it I think I wonder if she
had another Whittemore have you seen her
natural like are you like yeah rather
home she's fine and what was she a
blonde or something naturally she's been
dyeing her hair for so long I think
she's great naturally is that possible
now yeah I think she's blonde
yeah no crazy yeah yeah yeah you think I
should take the 10:10 p.m. flight or the
11:15 p.m. plate to go what time you
trying to get in
what's the thing they get in about an
hour apart either 645 or 7:40 can you
check into your hotel traffic where you
going to oh yeah you know whatever you
can start off in murder okay okay just
took me an hour I have to get to my
hotel when I did Gotham oh it's just
really not used underwear there's no
good subway system I know why it's a
cabs you didn't want to allow this I
better go over there
anyway I'm sorry child so do you think
it's rooted in your did you did you hate
your childhood is that why I loved it I
loved it seriously yeah child is the
best 20 pounds about okay sorry oh yeah
I don't have a crazy mom wait a minute
it was bare wait a minute not trying to
commit suicide in front of me yeah yeah
so but you didn't because you think that
somebody with my background because I
used to be like that to where I was
afraid of I didn't want a family I
didn't really think I would end up
married real kid like I but now that I
have it I love it because I love the
stability and this you find us with most
people oh right I have kids they're like
guys what I like yeah so how what like
where what was a defining moment for you
we were like I know I that for me I
think it's more reason where I was like
for a while I was like of course a lot
of kids exposed to do yeah you're 22
like and I less lost my religion and I
was like and I moved out here 25 and I
ask you this when you tell me one time
about no no about stopping the religious
thing how much you research that borrow
photo by clip real quick okay go ahead
so
I was it a lightbulb moment what what
what that like abandoning religion was
it like a one like you like dates back
to it to a thing it took me like a year
like ponder in my head until I realized
like oh but you really did ponder for a
while that yeah and what was the
Epiphany was it that God doesn't exist
or that this particular system of
religion is not it was and I don't have
a belief in it though I first I was
agnostic I was like I don't know it came
I was sleeping in a dorm near Shiva in
Israel and we had a light bulb over the
beds for reading and you could like
twist it up and I remember this I do you
see this is the story yeah yeah you
could put a cup on top of it
so Jonathan light so look cool I could
sleep but then the cup kept like sliding
off cause it's like circular frame to it
just kept sliding out sounds like maybe
let's turn the light off but my door was
like I window was like right by the
entrance to the dorm so I'm like people
going to see if I turn my light off and
it's everyone's like religious Jewish
you can't do it on Friday night oh sorry
we weren't allowed to have a nice gift
for carries electricity bit yeah you can
leave it on all the whole time or you
can turn it off the whole time oh but it
can't go one or these right so drowning
it out is okay still are not changing
miss Bart this is such weird [ __ ] but
like yeah a distinction to make
yeah it's funny too how many of those
things are like tied to a practice and
they become symbolic but but but their
actual origin is not something like no
it's not like like like I'm saying like
with food eating let's say like people
stay away I don't know from certain
foods but the origin of that was like a
practical thing you know right they
would say like something like some foods
wouldn't you know hold well for certain
people get sick so they go we don't eat
that and then years later they don't get
sick that a lot of fingers not anything
yeah yeah why like you did become
symbolic I'm just eating not the ribose
always so the reason we don't eat stuff
about because of like tapeworm or
anything yes because God said oh never
mind
practical reasons but that's probably if
God was invented that's probably what
one of the things is so it's a way so
we're in his epiphany though I think oh
yeah okay so the thing Wednesday on I
kept taking like I'll just turn my light
off I just turn it off what you're not
allowed to do but I was I can get it
caught and then I thought about it later
it was like who my work
caught by Brian man or God right and if
I really believe in God who didn't want
me to do that then I wouldn't be a
question you don't do that
yeah so I was it why am i questioning it
and it finally came to like I don't
think I believe in God hmm I don't think
it's in me and then once I figured that
out I was like I think I should stop I
went to talk about he turned that light
off huh where were you admission to the
University in New York and like Spanish
Harlem 185th and Amsterdam he went to
Taco Bell I want to talk about a bar
yeah what did you order what was the
honor
again we're not goes left for [ __ ]
one dollar whatever it is I don't know
if we because the shitty food or guilt
I'm not really sure we've been such big
fans of Neal Hamlin yeah I'm so glad
you're bringing this up that up uh we're
always going up right now Neal
hamburgers yeah did you start your trade
Neal Handleman yeah you know him right
oh so funny his Twitter feed is great oh
really
oh he doesn't have semi-regularly um
where I want to talk about this brown I
had yeah make I know let her go let's
not lose track of his uh his story here
either but I have to just mention that I
love him to get so much stuff going on
you gotta like yeah all right down so he
finds people's tweets yeah about incest
from Taco Bell really and research
there's a lot of them oh my god like
it's constantly go ahead read it out
loud I want to talk about one time Bubba
left uh I had it I looked at the Taco
Bell I work at got mice and bugs all
over the place the stick of [ __ ] a
[ __ ] gets food poisoning from talk
about cuz I know diamonds because or
cousin okay I did a presentation today
I'm back on a bacteria causes food
poisoning I think I got for drew to talk
about ironic good spot
saga boy again spread to cover talk
about talk about for the people who's
over there at the calculation a finite
number years the wheelers Berg pocket
well as well food anyway it's a it's a
kind of all my point force
yes you're all my car market
and he does this every few months Wow
one day it was like isolated over three
years
and I found a roach my food never went
back they also wrote [ __ ] I'm a taco
bell I'm a cart had a whole sigh gasps
ratchet chilled all of it
[Laughter]
so the talk about diarrhea thing is true
all right here's why golf go blue Taco
Bell three years ago what to Los Lunas
New Mexico talk about founder here
enough doc today Thunder here on our
food before we close yeah oh my friend
gaps
Wow and went to the hospital went again
the next day and got bad I can't believe
it yeah
Taco Bell never fails to give me food
poisoning your nasty-ass food
establishment gave me food poisoning
casual well never again if you just
search food the worst food poisoning I
talked about I think you set the search
taco we're talking about I okay go yeah
so training three different times
okay creation I done went I I want to
talk about survivor second Mount Vernon
and I done got boys I got some [ __ ] like
God bro really be shouldn't yeah I am
great on an account Oh Fanny can I was
her I almost my heart but isn't the the
amount of them astounding like many
people lar this is countless well I you
know the meat is supposably supposedly
worse than present about this blessed
one here every Taco Bell again that
should has a [ __ ] stick well excess I
don't care for your choice of words but
just said Tibet I can oh damn that's
right yeah I love what a good comment
like that just centers on something I
did there was a Colin Quinn's like
tongue-in-cheek like we're conservative
tweets yes his Twitter account ever
never lets in I'm joking never know that
would be like yes it's party you have to
like really accept that that that
there's gonna be people out there that
believe that you're serious yeah I think
that's a real struggle for like a lot of
calm
and I think that he is so yes that he
fully goes for it also you don't fool
people she's not quite as fun exactly
Eddie Kaufman how to get people like get
the [ __ ] off stage or doing I like his
stuff like there's just nothing like
hearing laughter out there the human
power of laughter with my Colin sweets I
hate it yeah yeah that's a smart move
because we would have done that with
Rogan
let's see instead of covering it up
inside covering your phone no I think
that that might be I don't think it's
made for that exactly your mom's I made
for this hey dude what are you doing
sorry your mama's made for hooking up my
mic Thanks well she anyway area I'm glad
you're here because you and I we share a
common bond that we both love to [ __ ]
and shower yeah every time I mention it
people like Oh Chris you know Mike yeah
I guess your job ah kindred post there
really are yeah really well we got this
bidet toilet first you go straight to
the shower you save money on toilet
paper first of all that's not the point
but it is it's a second of all it's the
clean as you can get it's the cleanest
you know drawing your drawing now what
led you to [ __ ] to shower I want to talk
about your experience I believe the
first time was kind of like my Epiphany
with Judaism where just like it just
sort of happens you know I was had no
toilet paper uh I looked under the sink
oh dude yeah I think this in my old
place on Sunset I really just think I
was like not I'm like [ __ ] what am I
going to do huh and then it hit me
straight to shower straight yeah that's
interesting because necessity is the
mother of invention is now with me it
was that I have what is known as the
never-ending wipe I get leaky but where
I Wi-Fi Wi-Fi wipe and the papers always
Brown and I found that the only way Lord
of it I would man stop the breath is if
I shower my butthole then the brown
stops coming down you get like greasy
greasy leak really just solid Brown no
no it's like a mush just like a like a
schmear oh yeah like I don't know I
don't know what that is uh-huh like a
sun-dried tomatoes cream cheese yeah
but anyway we got this new toilet this
robot toilet that those are great it's a
wash lead it's a bidet in your turlet
and you don't have to go into the shower
physically because some of that's
annoying like I wanted my pants off yeah
I'll dry off this ring though missing
what's amazing is you have different
water pressure options Oh oscillating
pulsating options what do you mean water
temperature options yeah cold warm huh
yep it's pretty amazing so basically you
can you're done yeah you have a nice
stream to kind of start kind of get your
[ __ ] agenda right yeah and then you
can [ __ ] gas it up and have a fire
hose Wow and really get good Connolly
that you can beat you can let that thing
run for a minute put toilet paper back
there nothing clean as a web and there's
a dryer copper will explain this me
wants about wet wet wipe I suppose a dry
one you know what though I find what I
said effective I don't think that's
enough well just in general using water
yeah yeah he said he's not just total JV
he's back that and he goes on how you
catch do so bit yeah and he was like
look at he took some a little bit of
coca-cola yeah put it on my table and
then he goes okay let that sit for a
minute now wipe it up with a dry towel
and now seal the table I'm like yeah a
little stick he goes yeah a little
sticky
yeah yeah right even water I didn't know
that he was such an expert I have
further questions for REM so fascinated
why not talk about Southeast Asia toilet
but ball I can't ok wait while I save it
say no wait wait well I'm been dying to
talk to you about this ok so now when
you do [ __ ] to shower in your world you
do a cursory wipe an exploratory wipe or
you literally dump your [ __ ] straight to
shower without even a cursory wipe ok
I'm going to ask you of your opinion
later what do you do okay
occasionally I'll go nothing ok doesn't
really I'll do a lot of new wife because
like what did you drip on the way
depends if I have a bath mat there you
have it I don't want to run a bath mat
full dump full dump just stand up and go
in the shower
well I can reach over from the toy I
turn the hot water on
other places a little harder but yeah
just go full and then you get to watch
all the [ __ ] run down this to think like
in psycho remember in psycho which is
bleeding out and the drain blood yeah
you got that you guys have run down your
leg which is all usually horrible but
it's not gonna stick right your shower
you do okay now because that to me is a
little bold notice not all the time so
information and I do live with someone
so I try to be considered I wouldn't put
Dookie Zorawar he's on the bathroom but
he's going to shower they're after me
and I don't want [ __ ] in our shower so I
do an exploratory consideration wipe now
sometimes I have just known like that
wasn't a massive brown there's not
there's nothing on my [ __ ] that was a
clean break it's fun once K alright I'll
wipe you yeah boys this is the ticker
ticker so to the journalists writing
about life game I was like seven - okay
but uh yeah I've only done if I'm
confident that there's no brown on my
butthole I will just go straight to
shower if I'm confident and then
sometimes I am never bleed out of my
vagina yeah all roads yeah that's normal
yeah you are you still bleeding out of
your [ __ ] not through my whole trip
in Southeast Asia when I got back by the
second day was full blood ago no rippers
really talked about this what do you do
it Wow do you think that I thinking an
internal hammer I have to ask the doctor
he's like you're good but Bloods too
dark you see yes in Asia so far yes yeah
loot I don't know it she's why she'd
been ill this can we play food any other
two seem shocked or animating flute was
her regime
why did you do that did you push out
there that way no I've never been able
to queef on command now oh good he's
loving it laughs he's like what the
that's a real talent though yeah also
playing a tune just blowing out anyway
he's also hitting beep that's right it's
a real skill anything like that you see
ah last time I went to Thailand like two
years ago we put a map on the street in
Thailand at a with Katie's women that
Bangkok
yeah Bangkok they gave you a rolled-up
piece of uh well first I give you a
balloon I cold it above your head and
you're like why Blake and then they
shoot darts out of the vaginas and pop
your balloon Wow
then you applauded for that ice oh yeah
it's not sexual at all it's just Talent
it's not sexual then you roll up the
paper to a funnel hold that over your
head what are you doing and then they
start peeling bananas and you're like no
my stupid out is out and get it into a
little cup you've made impossible what's
the trick what's the there's there's got
to be a circus trick there but ya know
electronic ehome that can't be legit no
way man that you think that's rely on
their bare mouth I've seen I'm gonna sue
them yet you know he pops out no I don't
have a vagina I don't know
wow we have to be able to suck air in
before you let the object in cause I've
seen girls like in queef on command I've
had friends that can do it yeah and you
lay on your back and you suck in the air
I don't made that did that was [ __ ]
reassured out stuff no no just the air
thing but on like he would just get on
he could do it on all fours lay on his
back and just all day he goes really
yeah wow what a town what a superhero
it was really cool yeah yeah I wonder to
have like a wrestling style school for
that for shooting somebody a vagina
where it's like you're not ready yet but
I want to get my accreditation for this
so let's talk about the toilets in Asia
okay so they have these if they're not
squat toilets I hate those yeah they're
pretty but and I hear that it's better
for you blah blah blah
yeah I love how much grievance committee
to remove yourselves some people
actually hiring us we just do stuff like
that like okay all right no apology
necessary to like oh yeah
somebody you know I was an Asian person
saying it so that's not impressive yes
change on this they're just giving out
directions who knows so they have the
squatters that this guy I hate that a
lot of times I they have toilets and
hostels without their toilets but they
have these bum guns which is just like
you know how want to sink you'll get
like the thing you get to pull out their
egos that yeah but without the what's it
called the spray yeah it's just a stream
and you put that into your butt mmm more
job and you just spray it out and then
like you said get that one wipe and it's
almost clean did you like that did you
prefer that to you all the shower yeah
you can't throw out I got used to it no
[ __ ] showers the best but you can't
throw your toilet paper in the toilet
right they also love to go in the trash
can I file is [ __ ] it smells horrible
yes I know words one of my good friend
it married a woman from chaotic Oh oh my
god and when her family came they were
so so out the trash cans toilet paper
like but like I used toilet paper toilet
paper as you guys don't have a bum gone
to like oh yeah so this is their nasty
clods of [ __ ] ah like they're getting
one last wife they're doing the whole
thing here and he was like you're not
doing this and they just don't know a
[ __ ] walking like their 40 years of
doing this yeah right like what
sometimes keep it flush Wow yeah that's
that's the opposite of that in those
hospitals like hey I know we're used to
where you are as you can't flush close
yeah uh hey I had a question oh hey we
had an email today
how do blind people know when to stop
wiping what are your thoughts on that
taste test I mean their sense of taste
is higher than most people yeah yeah
yeah cause I really thought it was a
thing where they eventually do a bare
hand thing and then they just go oh
there's nothing there yeah maybe but
they'd have to like they couldn't go
like happy I wonder how close I am right
right like you look at toilet paper when
you're out you don't have a shower you
look at it you're like okay about
halfway there you look like recorders
the way there yeah it's true
you don't just keep going into like this
finger I've been way down
right right right maybe maybe you smell
the toilet paper why do you have to
smell your bare hand
I don't know anything rail that's a
great week what you just did right
stepped it up a great way what you
saying because I'm an observational
person that you why why do they have to
smell their bare hand like you said why
not smell the toilet paper oh I see yeah
because one of them told me that's what
they do
really oh so I got this for you we're at
the park with Ryan O'Neal yeah and uh I
mean Tammy where Griffith Park someone's
just walking around we're taiking okay
and uh ten minutes in I was like fine
[ __ ] this morning I have to shake ha ha
Kendra he's like really Mike no hold it
hold it three more minutes like I'm not
holding it man
I gotta go he's like how you gonna wipe
I'm like well he had a full bottle of
water I might put that he said what do
you what what do you mean no don't do
this and I was like yeah I had the
sports top No ah what edge is just kind
of like one of these yeah Arrowhead
bottle and then uh [ __ ] on a hill so a
really squat shot which I'm used to now
I've got experience if you get away from
people yeah I got out and down the hill
a little bit cut to it got to like a big
bunch behind me so people are on the
road it could be your way down and you
looked up you could for sure see a manic
water if I was homeless I'd have a shirt
on yeah so yeah let's talk about the
squatting technique because I imagine
what's problematic is that you might
[ __ ] on your jeans
absolutely so how do you learn to lean
backwards there's also I hold your jeans
forward yeah yeah demonstrate make sure
to get this on camera yeah okay I don't
know I want to watch every don't pull
your pants down
I mean your your underwear down yeah I
don't need to see that much get the idea
from can we go around the corner they're
beautiful thank you Daenerys okay saris
got his pants down right now he's got
some mushroom boxer shorts on
and he's standing and so I don't see a
kid
all right pulled his pants down
he's underwear dan please put them back
on for the lab we have dogs in here okay
he's showing oh yeah because of you
please don't play your pan so let's
assume that okay so you don't want [ __ ]
just wanting B right into the pant he's
squatting but you're squatting straight
so everything's at a perfect angle okay
so you're hanging though your answer
though above okay so you really look
cute you really squat back a little bit
you stop this walk you squat full shoe
on back my balls right Tom cow God
touching the toilet is a real issue in
people like big long balls so that's an
issue but I wasn't at the park
no big deal right now when you are doing
that at Griffith Park what about the
weeds and the brush touching your dick
in your balls in your butthole and all
that some dried leaves definitely
touched yeah didn't care for it so
you're saying it's all about the lien
like what you kind of did the way you
are squatting is how I've seen like
Chinese guys smoking in Chinatown yeah
they're used to it they always get like
that
yeah but yeah this whole back squats up
with um pant your balls are so big so
big so then I pour water in my hands
immediately as it's wet took it to the
butt and kind of wiped oh you think you
did it with your hand yeah and then got
more water wipe more water wise no
didn't dig in with nails did 189 nails
ma'am and then I was forced by Ryan to
wipe my hands in dirt afterwards okay
and then you wash your hands later I'm
hope and yeah how much like do you get a
lot of ball attention when you're like
are they like all these are great balls
like is a big thing
couple times yeah I've had a couple
girls go like man I love these balls
really but like twice now are you really
into your own balls then like is that a
big like if you're making your list
you're like definitely like play my
balls
I think immediately they're good weapons
yeah how saggy they are yeah I mean if
there were nice tight ones it wouldn't
be as funny but they're really well why
is it really a turn-on saying like if if
you were like if a woman was like what
what do you like what we're about to
have sex we like definitely play my ball
no not okay so like your thing I don't
mind it's kind of nice actually but it's
not like I need that it's not you need
it no I love you I mean I like it but I
mean it's not like I wouldn't be like if
you don't find my balls we have
to the deal breaker how big were re
balls they just live like I am not look
what it looks like there was like six
balls the left would hang about lower
like a good like a half matted pizza
dough kind of things just like I think
real already didn't look too hairy down
there I got a glimpse sound like a
teenager's beard of occasion or you do a
lot of trimming or no nothing really
good second I got I got to do a lot of
that really are
Georgia linear no no Argentinian what
are you keep a Peruvian Rubio yeah and I
you know whatever but um it's a lot I
don't know it's a lot of hair I'm not
like actually I have one of my friends
you like it him fall down they're not
bald
I like a good clean up I I think that
it's important to at least be a little
hygienic yeah I don't like so much hair
that it's annoying it too much
yeah it can get away from you you know
we can but stop storing at some point
though yeah it does but yeah I look down
there on my pouf yeah you sneeze I mean
I just need like a haircut you don't
want to talk yeah no nuts grows and then
it's to Velcro a when it's too long
sometimes look like the head just like
peeking out of the woods you know work
something like what's going on like
Groundhog Day
you know to see what about a few weeks
of well back in yeah so your polyps is
that what you have polyps is that in
your butthole you said you have
hemorrhoids
next time I go and can you do something
to stop them from oh no he said I could
have surgeries is not worth it cat seems
like it might not work and it's just
like invasive and you've never have you
ever seen gieux clam excuse me are you
gonna show I don't know I know no I
don't know right now I can't do it
doesn't sound good really it's so bad I
thought in person I was like were you
there when it happened dude I was in a
capsid I was in cap city yeah I'll try
to really put that video out so promote
my special you know I I gotta saw it and
I remember that I pulled I was so
traumatized that I pulled Brian aside so
quiet like he needs a hospital and I
designated like that I know it's great
but now five of us is I was really and
that isn't a proud that shouldn't be
surgery yeah yeah silligan whatever but
just that you bleed a lot and I'm sorry
[ __ ] my it's like I mean you really got
to see it I don't need to I can dice
what we already have to blur one Tom's
episode yeah it's so great
like his basically his you ever seen
like a chimps ass yeah it's like bubbles
that's like all big and like a prolapse
yes yes
okay well zolina pops that happen
elapsed vagina book that happened to him
on camera Oh Gina I saw him turn it what
I thought I was like I literally who
does that I never seen anything like
this I saw this swollen Yanks sticking
out of him like peach bread ha ha ha ha
and it met it looked like I brought up
look it wasn't like your real [ __ ]
I've been trying to push out a [ __ ] for
like the last like three four straight
minutes and I thought that's what it was
that [ __ ] was halfway out of my butt
hello just trying to show you you saw it
Lincoln's you knew what that was what it
looked like oh no I thought there was a
piece of [ __ ] coming out of my butt and
I was trying to show you that oh the
most about anyone you so hot on yourself
were you a little like oh my god like
yeah yeah okay yeah legs a little scary
right it was like yeah yeah yeah but I
was like I can essentially been there
for a while why did that that didn't
feel good yeah you're right ring your
wife it it's fine it's pretty tough and
then it just kind of goes back in goes
back in yeah
what was it alright I mean we've already
I don't know is it when I get a good one
not on YouTube I think like liveleak or
something okay I don't know if I
uncensored answered you clam it's still
like that re I can show you right now no
no that's okay
bubby yeah that's a terrible thing to
live I got it I got a bleep some punch
ugh ah oh I saw that on the I saw that
yeah some Tripoli's saying how's that go
did it hurt no a little warm a little
little like heat on it but uh did you
get to see it before and after shot like
so you can see about Cena before
or after it just seemed like the parts
that he didn't bleach were just darker
didn't look like it was lighter that's
so fine that people are doing that is
that real I mean if you're a porn star I
get it but otherwise in civilian life
why would you need to have your [ __ ]
I mean let's take down to an accident
and you badly burned inside your [ __ ]
that's a static sky rock won't slow down
won't blow I'm just like I'm trying to
play it and because all my work
yeah well it just says you know so I go
hit play I'm hitting play right now
calling video gets its horrific nudity
he can't be over there just won't play
forward Wow this other one will play
here's a reddit link to it maybe this
will play maybe that this is fun
I peed the dish yeah I'm thinking again
one of those bidets eggs dude Amazon
you'll have to shift or like get in the
shower it's a truck dude I haven't [ __ ]
the shower I only do it in hotels now
because well yeah they don't now I feel
like a diminished degrade a human when I
have to [ __ ] on a toilet that doesn't
have a bad day I feel like it's I feel
like trash so used to it
ah it's going to change your life it's
called the Toto wash let 350 e Washlet
wash let wash lid I don't know what do
you why is thing like that is it Tom is
it wash let or Washlet Washlet
oh I thought it was French maybe like to
even an Ian wash little bit no look Jack
of it I don't know if I could know but
it'll really change your whole [ __ ] game
yeah I might do is give you blood and
stuff down there you should work so now
when you do that yeah then does it stop
with a continuous wiping yeah it's good
cleans it up well the water is what I
need to stop bleakie but well I don't
know why my Platt leaks have you ever
before you got that you ever wipe say
okay I think I'm good then go out and go
I think I'm I think I gotta go back to
white that's how I've discovered my
leaky blood problem yeah yeah and then
like hours later I'll be like oh my god
what why is there Brown there these
these summer days by the way now and
summer oh we actually I mean I'm Harry
yeah
like sometimes I'll be like my ditches
and
down with paper yeah see if there's
something there you sexy so much Brown
just like sweat and your your food if
you walk around New York City it's the
same way yeah hi just hot wait are you
going back then yeah I'm going back on
uh going back on Saturday it's kind
first oh you are okay yeah so we go yeah
I'm gonna be there like a couple weeks
just hanging out if you want to come by
the road then stay indefinitely oh hey
can we see what's up with Danny AK Danny
AK yeah she's a lady she's got a falling
on good on YouTube pull yakimaniac
yeah yeah I mean you know I just been
thinking about her yeah well she does
this thing or like she starts basically
all of her are a lot of her videos like
this she goes
hey what Hitler yes she holds a sentence
longer than Hitler
how does that work oh really yeah yeah
yeah she's just addressing all this up
to Hitler yeah it's a live Hitler that I
back then Hitler I think they did a lot
in distinction okay yeah the historical
Hitler Hitler of today how did she give
him like blog type advice or she like
admonishing you for some of the stuff
you've done or she's like are you doing
she's like I need some help oh really
yeah it's a crisis Wow yeah tell you
that Daniel is basically harassing my
day accent he's harassing me he's a
threatening actually Jonas buzz Bajada
raper you call me a dick and a raper
something like hmm you know sacrifice oh
really
to another demon army called peak you
he's been suspended in my account like a
thousand of times because he is overly
jealous she's real
a thousand of times he basically is
obsessed with me he doesn't know
anything about me
right she's in no rush to get to a point
hello girl all the time in the world
me no watch'n you do he loves you too
but you know what in Patagonia I just
wanted her what is YouTube oh yeah all
right can we see that the update yeah uh
37 thousand views it's not that yeah
well that's thank you we've been Pesce
as she said I think you guys know what
should be upset you had a Jew on your
podcast I don't know yeah real probably
does she say anything at they Semitic or
yeah I think she don't remember I don't
remember honestly with her that had an
anti a thousand upon me I just want to
let you know the people in San Antonio
the ones and just call me my damie axe
um they perfectly are chained up on the
candy third and which I've already and
change them but um the Hubble I know I
thought that was wrong know if the title
is all right right right there on a
scampi boat
yeah sure save them and I really need
your help and I'm saving them well
Hitler has to do it
thank ya I'll be saw on the but untied
yeah we're killer going to do their that
she hasn't already done she's a hero
yeah maybe like this is the one I'm
talking about
I mean why aren't you I didn't answer
the shrimp scampi boat and getting
turned and doing but Guangzhou yeah
especially from this day we don't hey
Deenie i/o show is it is good well I
don't know there are at least two and
idea all right
realizing oh they're on the shrimp
scampi hey lis me Dini I just want to
let you know there are at least the two
my DX or Elise's a few my Danny actor on
the shrimp scampi votes like they are
like getting turned into lasagna so I am
gonna need your help getting and we're
in advance keepo overwhelmed and they
they really need your help getting
rescued
so could you hilly please please a send
a rescue boat why won't help with my way
make a change
hmm her point was appreciated days okay
baby she says hit what she sang hitler
baby oh for christmas and she sings
happy but it learn and other people have
access to submarines it's right i mean
it's not out of the realm of like no
[Music]
lips
what's a good dog I've ever been yeah
every birthday yeah [ __ ] lips yeah I
don't know if she's saying that Alex
Sylvain stuff
Oh shrimp scampi boat problem Celia ways
actually again anything is to actually
say Happy Easter
Wow okay oh man that would that would
have made all those even movies way
lamer yeah the thing I was looking for
is do you remember her one of her og
ones was about [ __ ] around yeah I
can't find around
that's hard to find yeah we could be
looking all day for that I know but she
had a great one about what she was going
to do to this guy when she and she's
gonna [ __ ] in his mouth and not around
it she like specified where she was
getting really yeah yeah you know Hitler
could only get hard if you show us just
yeah no no you can talk about it like he
had a small dick and then he had a yeah
that's why I always fair where I was
growing a latent homosexual and I was
growing up around people who didn't like
Hitler why don't we move there from I
think they were just not fans of the EU
yeah try to unite yeah yeah all right
you should do would you rather with Arry
would you rather yeah like the
historical one the big one okay there's
a couple I got I just think it'd be fun
to play with them yeah would you rather
only lasagna for the rest of your life
yeah or never have to never be able to
eat anything with meat No one day one
day at one meal a day how the really
going to fill up your life before or no
meat string the top layer hominis itchy
ass it's time to play schedule efficient
Joe that's terrible not until the urine
from T during homeless and which are why
my brothers in it always a joy that glad
your sister they do the face dinner
destroyed the grandmother walked in on
you masturbating never have another
orgasm time ago
I like what I want to hear every I want
to hear my options again it's either
lasagna one meal a day for the rest of
your life every day you had every day
you must see it was not behind is it
meat and veggies it was your choice okay
but you can't anything else kind of like
a little piece of lasagna and like a
salad is just lasagna fermium one meal a
day yeah you have two pieces three
business but for the rest of your life
you get other meals dinner yeah that
could just be lunch okay but you don't
get to like have another thing late you
have to eat it it's a fill-up on it okay
you know it's a it's a beautiful meal or
you're vegetarian only but you're saying
no fish as a vegetarian so no protein
you basically have to be like a V you
may have eggs I say I have to have that
protein I feel I feel weary when I don't
have protein
yeah I'm gonna have to go with the
lasagna once a day well cuz I like
lasagna like I really I could do that
and you don't feel like you'll be
betraying lasagna by eventually hating
it no okay no what do you say Tommy
jeans I have to do this right now
okay we are airy what do you choose hmm
let's think of what I said it do love
meat lasagna every day I know it's tough
because you know when you make a lasagna
you end up eating it for three or four
days other than I like my day for you're
just oh no that's day so what was the
other option besides lasagna over here
be a vegetarian
no fish you can only have nine of eggs
who know well I think I'd have to do
lasagna every single day you know so
what did you eat a tiny square no no not
alone you got a popular meal serving a
lot not allowed but here's the thing
the variety provided to you and the
other meals I think would we counter it
oh I feel weak when I don't eat meats I
like meat what if you had yellows on
influence got other why'd you go to a
dinner party like we got lasagna today
yeah I'm gonna kill someone yeah wait
what would you choose I think I'd be a
vegetarian okay
I think I would get real sick lasagna
and I'd start to go crazy that's true
what could you have different lasagnas
like with a bechamel sauce one day I'd
have to be in standard tomato
water-filled wait pictured it was the
same exact recipe lasagna like when you
said you liked the finger lasagna keep
eating it imagine like a 50-mile long
one always lasagna you can have either
fresh or heated up that's the only
variety you got
I put shaky cheese on it one day the
next day no shaky I try to vary it I
think I would have to do that just to be
able to have whatever I want for the
second or third meal I agree I agree
okay Airy ready yeah that's probably
going this is probably one of our most
favorite would you rather Zahn the show
very popular would you rather be
[ __ ] hold on I'll stop you there I
would love to I mean let's get another
positive or be a millionaire that I
don't know but like I would love real a
lack of responsibility you will feel
would be so worth it you really need to
throw in I mean you know in the towel
I'm gonna throw it high Oh who's going
to do that chore well for sure not me
right cuz I'm [ __ ] and so for sure
it's on me you guys can decide who's
doing it but I'm out of this can I just
go pee corner what did they make you
have a job like you have to go it how
many choice or glass remember that
commercial - you're little I saw that
don't throw me away come on fella yeah
we played it on the show really yeah you
have to go work at the grocery story not
the bag groceries George push carts
yeah stuff like that you get a [ __ ]
guy bagging your groceries the part of
you feel like part of the solution
yeah I like it I've said today my
favorite was I loved doing this to
people I do this to my mother we were at
a grocery store and they had a party guy
has his bag in the groceries and he was
at this grocery so they walk you to the
car - so they walk you the car and they
loaded in - so he did he did all that
there's no conversation and as we're
getting into content
it's almost different about that guy
right [ __ ] he also doesn't know like
any other DC things to say and she I go
know was she was don't mean please I go
he's fine he was like off and clearly
yeah and she just like just upset I do
that also when I see like somebody
walking at like you know you're go to
[ __ ] with her know yeah like what's then
with my parents I'll be like drunk and
about 0 Paul we are still that and
should be like it but they don't like
they don't go they don't get that I'm
saying that as a jokes I do it seriously
and then they'll be like that guy's
severely snoring like he's he's [ __ ]
oh I love it and I lie and I'm like he's
drunk you can tell I like it on my
friend like oh look at this hot girl and
I turn it's like some 80 year old
[ __ ] [ __ ] because we're expecting
to see somebody super hot you know I
like what Tom does is when you see the
pregnant woman he'll be like what's
wrong with her stomach I'm drinking down
here I've heard Steve that I posted it
on Instagram before yeah it's almost
like that Colin Quinn thing we're
talking about duplicate earlier pregnant
no did I post it with Adam West ugh yeah
without I always I have this contract my
fans I was so a celebrity dies as soon
as possible I will [ __ ] on as soon as
they die as soon as I hear about it I
will try to come with a funny tweet
[ __ ] on them yeah not respecting her
death yeah so for Adam West so they
don't really have any problems at all
with Adam West
yeah I was like Adam West [ __ ] my
grandmother
it's for apartment fat my father's found
I saw that I'll never forgive him a dad
Moshe kasher was like is that real
goodness talk I just like an idiot no
you're lucky I didn't [ __ ] my soft oh
yeah so are I tore my family apart
that's why on the real though I mean I
want you to be really really nice or sir
would you rather be [ __ ]
or let your grandfather jerk you off on
a ferris wheel but but and get you get a
funnel cake there go ahead I think it's
choose the ferris wheel
you got a pair of funnel cake yeah right
that's not but I'd bet all he does like
he jerks you up on no one finds out
they'll get an awesome fresh funnel cake
yes go ahead
does a funnel cake come before after the
joke on some affairs yeah after so it's
like you're done right you're crying so
don't think you feel better right now
ice cream after you yeah he goes like
this thing like don't tell anybody whose
phone the final take yeah I feel like
the experience of having a funnel cake
with with Papa would be sort of tainted
from the jerk-off it is your is but you
here's the thing it's no confidence you
have the final cake before it be a nice
moment my with my papa my Saba but then
afterwards to be like nothing to wash
down that bad feeling
yes Abba like a Jew the odds grandfather
got you bro there's a tough one see ya
thank you now my Saba going I survived
the Holocaust for this fulfill would you
rather from Christians but okay so but
you're either [ __ ] your whole life
or you do one bad incident on the ferris
wheel but there's funnel cake I approved
Jews and you got to consider that you
might be get Y into it and then one how
that happened over and over that's not a
really it's not just a one-time thing
sure I don't I don't talk off to anime
porn for that reason why is that what if
I I don't want to go down that road
right you know and then be like start
turn off the cartoons it's too dark a
road
so you're saying yeah yeah I think I
would go with my I mean is it now as he
was still alive they're both dead yeah
so I mean they're still alive he's alive
oh yeah yeah not digging up his core
he's always going as Ferris well this is
an interesting distinction Ari's making
because if it happened to you in your
formative years in your youth it could
do long-lasting damage if it happens at
what age are we talking your child and
this happens are you an adolescent or
are you 40 something year old also if
you're an adolescent if you're a just 17
you're going to come quick sure but now
I mean she's going to be jerking me off
for a while like I'd ever go to the guy
running like run back run that back we
could go another
right so well that's an interesting
[ __ ] hands I hope there's their Lube
is it Lube or that is that rough now now
grandpa and rock yes yeah Rob all right
now I think I think you know what I'm
going to do with this one cuz I hadn't
considered the age I don't want to scar
you emotionally too much so I'm not
going to attend it to a child from now
on I'm gonna go that's great 40
something year old is nari you're an
adult and your grandfather is like a
couple years before he dies Rex was old
his hand all decrepit but also I get to
have had 40 years of non [ __ ] life
any day right doesn't go back and become
always try to agonize so you'll be born
[ __ ] and winter semester comes out
like a bison been [ __ ] interview
talking about it so why don't you do a
double special I like TV no interesting
and I like going on with you right now
yeah I play would you rather I know this
married couple the sort of fake and
phony no yeah I didn't what common my
friend my grip on something mood is no
because if you had to live the rest of
his life return it that'll be really
crazy oh wait it did not look much
really
well that's what I thought I had assumed
that you'd be born we go back in time
and you're born [ __ ] but we got to
make choices right now so you can
convert us all right now so that's why I
think it might be funnier it's from now
I think it's better though it's better
to listen listen from that from now on
you're [ __ ] from now on you know be
hard to because I've gotten laid and
then the amount of game I would not have
your career
unless you become the [ __ ] comedian
now
my insolence wouldn't be there to write
the bits but here's your thing we can
hire dart getting do you start getting
sympathy tail be Appa sure yeah you
don't look the same way people remember
you before you walk into a bar and then
they're like hey I saw your Netflix and
call me central yeah you would get a
bunch of women who would like we're
already look to me like whatever like
but not enough yellow is my favorite
yeah and then they like oh wow I kind of
think for a Tartar people yeah also he
was a funny comic once this okay you
give off a whole new line your sex game
would be to take a big dive you would
never think about pleasing somebody else
no but you got also things I have [ __ ]
strength yeah so and a [ __ ] libido
don't forget they are very sexually and
they took off constantly because they
don't know like you're not supposed to
do this like why would you not serve
good you have to try it what we got
right we got hate mail about that really
should she said that and some someone
wrote in like I work with in special ed
she's like they don't all jerk awful
that you [ __ ] me that's good you've done
good job
they are so mad every obsess we're going
to get some mail on this to think yeah
but it's so where that emails never like
oh just you know some of them do that
but generally it's like 510 percent
you're off a little bit yeah [ __ ] you
asked for yeah is really I go right
thanks for not teaching let me ask you
this though yeah you know you're gonna
have a decision but go hood yeah yeah
yeah okay but then walk us through the
logic I'm not here yet tell us your
decision and tell us why you chose that
yeah I think I would go with my
grandfather jerk me off
Wow I just don't want to be [ __ ] man
I just don't i [ __ ] and i thought
some gross people before yeah this would
be way more damaging but i wasn't that
close with Papa or estaba
how long do you think it would take you
to finish it would take a while what
time I tried to jerk off before the two
guys in the Lavoie Comedy Store the
condo I try to work it up like real hard
in the other room yeah and then come out
and like choose in front of them and
yeah when I came out realize how
ridiculous it was it I was about to come
and then it was on I you got a five
minutes now and I need to go back
I'm usually there furiously nervous was
it the pressure of performance it was
just like ridiculous it's funny
he's were they laughing with a one was
laughing one was in horror well I think
I choose a ladder yeah yeah yeah I'm
gonna go grandfather's jerking me off
Wow yeah it would be rough it would take
a while it would definitely damage me oh
man I would echo what the thing is that
it's going to go back the rest of your
life would have it definitely a new I
have my parents have trouble looking at
them yeah yeah especially telling them
like yes a towel Monday you know what
you know what your dad did didn't ya
game should really be called would you
least rather yeah of course you're not
worth it sit what about sort of leads us
into one of the classic would you rather
and I know you're not obviously
Christian but like the biggest
celebratory day in your house would
probably be like growing up would be
passing like what for celebration
oh you mean like pencils more like a
family thing yeah Monica Monica where's
your family they're though but everyone
see under now Passover Passover Rosh
Hashanah okay that's over for sure okay
Passover yeah
so it's Passover everybody gets together
oh my god I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
hahaha I am Baris home [ __ ] not you
leave a different but oh my god you guys
are so disgusting so if you guys have
your you know you said yeah you
sacrifice your baby you do your thing
oh the contours babies does right okay
he's a grown man he'll a dog you guys do
you change black your prayer you know
there is one drop of Jewish non Jewish
baby blood in the matzo recipe intensity
refer to it one drop in fact it's not a
whole baby women for sure we killed the
babies and put them out but like only
one job you're way off base
okay I don't know all the things but you
to your coin flip everyone sits there
and then at the end right is there like
a big toast and everything to just hand
board losses along ok so there's all
this wine then you say to your family
you go guys I got to show you something
and you everybody goes
from the dining room no I was just going
to living out like I don't know about
okay already push it out so everybody is
like all cooling and they're like what
is it you did you shoot a new show what
are you going to show us and you just
sit here and watch this and you put it a
DVD so and they're all like waiting in
their mom eating a Grammy and wouldn't
by the way is this a stir do you say
Happy Passover like what do you guys say
so happy what phrase aw happy Pesach
thanks Oscar
okay okay or to jump dos good yontiff
yeah okay so after all holidays so
they're all sitting in front of the TV
you press play your on screen and ten
homeless guys are standing around you
and all of its are like this and how it
goes
yeah this is one of the options of
course it's a video of both no no no no
it's one or the other oh I'm sorry
you're right I continued right go ahead
divorce over know about that we go that
B can be late okay okay okay so let's
say dome okay yeah yeah but their
homeland mixture is homeless
yes and they all masturbate to
completion yeah and Bollingen and he on
you know and they're squirting or no one
that oh and oh yeah because it could be
like squirt and they're like yeah
they're all really loud about it it's
really uncomfortable oh my boy I always
watching yes wait yes now when I leave
the back to everybody right yeah
although the latter one ends you turn to
camera and you say other place off yeah
happy pace off like that and then it
cuts to black you turn back and what do
you guys think it's either that or when
you put the DVD in and you press play
it's just you alone looking the camera
and you masturbate to completion and you
say happy here so yeah so it's the shame
that it's either you doing the thing or
having the thing done to you that's
shameful
I mean I there's so many different
people in the family so yeah well my mom
and dad events disappointed with me
versus like I could explain to the
nephews if I was just masturbating my
sister's could be like okay you're gonna
have to learn this eventually yet what
all he was doing was called masturbation
you'll do it when you get a little older
we have to take that can we take the
children out of the room I think the
children don't need to be privy I'm
going to take one no one needs to be
privy well let's let's change it to just
adults I don't think it's fair to put
kids and that's in there so I'm
picturing me when I was growing up they
going on like on 22 no one has it as
being right most kids yeah correct I've
always grown up correct it's just adults
only what we've changed it to Tom
children shouldn't watch the video
notice your mom is your dad it's your
grandma grandpa everywhere their mother
sister they were all there's no children
okay yeah so that's all the dollars okay
can I say a problem with us yeah I had
you can't use a DVD player on Ianto so
it would be okay every time like I got
to put this a DVD yeah like what are you
talking about well I have the caveat
here it is it's a live performance guys
kind of my friends they're all going to
do this with me versus all right guys
and actually the way I come to the
backyard
yeah always more actually originally the
way I like this one is to send out a
company-wide email guys come to my desk
at 12:30 and everyone shows up your boss
and then you're like and then you that's
a good way to masturbate that's a good
way to quiz job yeah but what would you
guys do with grandfather or [ __ ] I'd
rather go [ __ ] I'd rather
grandfather 100% yeah now weird lived a
great life I've all but my son [ __ ]
grandfather I have to raise my kid but I
feel like it would like it now that I
think about talking about with you it
would take so long we all go somewhere
like focus so intently on it you know
just you have to block out like so large
it's a really mistake about sexual stuff
yeah
har that you like at all top of it or if
you get that smell bengay yeah and every
time he's like Oh clean off throwing
he's like you know he wouldn't be good
at it so like he's a [ __ ] play lick
his hand the way doesn't
yeah I hope you like having trouble to
be like going to your balls and you're
like yes yes I need help in my lab like
old times yeah you want me to do your
balls yeah crazier ball game and balls
mama area so what's it going to be in a
bottle keg yeah so jerk off in front of
my family or have ten girls kind of boot
cocky you I mean originally it was ten
homeless men but I feel like we adapt it
for male but they're really I think I'm
men and women homeless okay and they're
being bored so if I'm roughs do it at a
homeless value that's what it sounds
like
[Music]
this is the fun of your family
like in the backyard
bathroom I mean are they just gonna
watch our like a god knows what now
everyone anyone just watching her just
like shocked yes senator yeah so you're
really thinking about the conversation
afterwards yeah talk us through your
thinking you okay you think about
afterwards how to deal with you're also
thinking about if no one was there which
I read it's like I don't want to have
homeless people [ __ ] on me I think
it's not just about the reaction it's
also think this is happening all right
my interesting point interesting but
can't you masturbate in front of your
family that's another thing looking in
your mother's eyes looking at your sit
right right yeah I mean like the
homeless people jizan on you into square
that could be a would you rather if the
family not even involved because it's
not even a good thing
yeah but the family adds a nice logo for
sure I'm saying it the facet but
masturbation without my family is no big
deal without your family their family
that's a whole other level that's why
it's such an important would you rather
this is a seminal one if you know hmm I
think I think I know but my thinking is
I think thank you I just want to know it
off to them it was like rock I was fast
to do this I wasn't the one doing it
that's right
that was a lot masturbating that's right
though it's a more normal thing like
obviously you know it's election that I
do this when you're not around right and
now the I am ready at the shoulder it's
a shame displacement it's either the
shaming is done to you or you're
responsible for your shame so that's I
think my psychologically very hawkish
as I'm talking to him I just wish yeah I
was going to go get get judged on right
but I think maybe now masturbating but
then again the conversation afterwards
maybe like no you were doing that are
you asked about why did you do it pass
we ask you to stop we're saying hey
please stop the other way it's like we
asked the homeless people to please stop
yeah and they did it alright get away
from them but I'm on the ground and they
have and they they take the
responsibility right what's happening
made him do this yeah oh they forced me
all right
I'm a I lost the butcher
this is a really underline one the goals
whenever you do it would you rather it's
not how people go oh yeah hey all right
yeah CF it's the dilemma yeah yeah I I
think forgetting masturbator log do you
prefer that one I don't prefer I don't
really like using that word so it's your
preference it's what we find enjoyable I
think that but there would be that
conversation of like I'm a severe was
you that in front of us but dislike to
what are you into but that's all that's
an interesting we're in commerce of our
son so that's interesting the shame of
what are your sexual preferences Mari
are you into this is what our ease into
versus we don't know what our ease into
but he's masturbating in front of us I'm
not I masturbated in their house while
they were there when I was an Orthodox -
right Alice time were you supposed to
not do that or for sure not there's no
religion in the world that I know of no
even that that says that allows it will
you ever bring stuff like that up in
that era would you be like I want to
masturbate or they talk to you that
stuff like that no no no even sex ed was
how are your folks yeah Orthodox Jewish
yeah yeah they have gotten to the point
whether if we're out my dad's like you
can I get a burger you can get a burger
oh really
but that like took a lot how are they
with your you know success like I like
my success they don't like the way I've
achieved it like when I took my dick out
on HBO my mother boy I told people to
watch you can see on TV are ey and like
mommy shouldn't watch the stuff it's
exactly not free will they watch the
special oh yeah they will yeah gee I got
Comedy Central before they got cable
just later watch me really yeah they're
proud of me as my aunt once I was doing
some joke about like herpes at the DC
Improv you know they were there and they
left right afterwards I was like what
did they how do they feel about that she
goes I think they just simply were
joking about like the setup and this
pale oh that it's all made up yeah yeah
that's good you here long I'm joking
about having it though not having it
[ __ ] excuse me making love to a woman
so I'll experience like love to a woman
who had herpes on there like I was just
so young it's amazing how many people
like well they're like until you just
made that whole thing up right
no I just chose the funniest way to say
yeah the amazing one to me is when
people think you made up like a super
detailed story like a story yeah
like people can they're like so you may
like I had a story about meeting Mike
Tyson and they're like you write all
that off you make that up I mean really
creative he could do I mean you kind of
want to be like yeah I think I'm
creative but like you think I mean I
made up all the beats of like our
Congress like that why would I like that
yeah but I guess if you don't do it then
you just they don't know don't let them
see behind the curtain guys come on I
know but it's just weird that like you
just know it's like when I've got a plan
like never do or what happens yeah yeah
now does your mom do the thing where she
when she gets her period she goes to the
water the jacuzzi look whoo yeah I like
that a lot
my mom hasn't gotten a period since
before Obama for sure yeah
probably been exact and I like that idea
yep connected what is it 40 almost of
natural water that's a measurement of
natural water you need okay after you
have your period you need seven clean
days so no spotting no nothing count one
two like popcorn with a pop so you're
like three seconds you go one okay
starting one two I want you know what so
you get seven clean days no spotting
everything to get a spot starts over you
get seven clean days in you go to the
mikvah ritual bath you can also use a
lake or ocean because it's got plenty of
water in there natural water but not
like a pool it's got to be like a
natural it's gotta be rainwater coming
in I always think about whenever I hear
these things like that it's crazy right
no just the amount of effort just an
effort I guess we're all well let me
tell you that in terms of like what you
said like practicality yeah so period
looks like three five days I'm sorry
yeah dead seven clean days now your date
twelve yeah so you're going to ovulate
Fiona the next day you go to the mikveh
13 and now you're you haven't [ __ ]
your husband in 1349 and you're at your
most fertile yeah it's great it's
actually a way of making area baby of
more juice and it's not so cute like
yeah I think also like just relationship
was you guys come to a road so like when
you're apart from each other when I'm
back in a comic can't wait to see you
yeah yes true versus you've seen a lot
of couples
Micra you sure that I do I like what the
Jews did okay I got some good [ __ ] yeah
what are you driving for anything you do
you have anything like symbolically
anymore
like to do anything besides masturbate
in front of your family booda sack I'll
get off on that because I grew up with
it yeah but it's on home I'll sing their
songs with them oh you know that just
sounds really at this point but do they
is everybody here's nothing
how are they as far as they have they
accepted your they are generative but my
dad once in a while so she talked to the
shoulder well you know come with friends
with no I feel bad last time I went home
so you say the grace after meals there's
this if you have three or more men above
13 there's an extra player say and one
person says that everyone like joins in
so you say like it's in Hebrew but you
say like blood sit on up for giving us
food and I was like yet for real don't
tell and it's like Thanksgiving here is
like - totally yeah it's a back and
forth a little bit yeah my dad's like
you want to leave this one I was like oh
no I remember he's like no you read
another book I was like I know my mom's
like do it I'm like I know but then as
soon as I didn't know like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me yeah just not you know
I'm not I'm not converting I could have
done it if I was at a Buddhist thing and
they said can you be this thing I would
have done it yeah so it's like that's
because it's family and two traditions
well not but I mean like I go bad about
it yeah can we get back to the [ __ ]
question at hand
yeah he hasn't chosen sorry so hard now
I've never had somebody somebody really
mold all there's already the before and
is a during the after the after the
doing explaining to them it's like of
course I mastered like watching you re
why now is masturbation so so taboo yes
it is for your house it's not a normal
thing it's not a natural occurrence
meaning that's the double thing of you
having Orthodox parents real is that you
know that's off the table discussion
Wi-Fi like white trash parents why are
you doing that outside no all right
hey what's your choice what is it
I I think it's the homeless people yeah
yeah I don't think that yes no I think I
I chose the other one I chose doing it
myself
he's got good parents I could tell them
afterwards the whole job like I wasn't
into that right right right right
no I understood I mean I I got it I I
just I thought I rejected all the other
come
no I displaced the shame I prefer to put
the shame on the other people what it's
going to be I'm not lying laughing I
later on not me and to them the oh gee
would you rather yeah it's great when
you come across a good one you like I
got numbers for next time this one is
like from yeah he's like a six or seven
year old one you know I won for you
for me yeah you could do is to marry
good okay Tommy would you rather would
you rather have your mouth smell like
beef see why do i dog our blonde dog
because smells like my smelly food is my
own it's like how much the other one I
look for you oh you don't like it now
it's like I a bit [ __ ] I'm gonna be
horrible yeah okay so would you have
either your mouth smells like beef or my
mouth smells like beef yours why why
really yeah
but they need to live with me and I'll
have a garbage mouth yeah I know I just
have you guy just kiss other parts you
know yeah but that would be the owner in
terms of like her feelings the perfect
woman you loved like it will be easier
for you right easier for me times your
mouth toid you not to smell his horrible
mouth he's going to have a bad smelling
mouth anyways because dads get dad mouth
you're going to have dad mouth in like
when you're 50 right don't dad's mouth
smell like [ __ ] anyway like older guys
Malaga we're saying ya know like those
do door they were putting on and they
and they look like like older guy mouths
would look like they're just decomposing
look at that nothing like you look like
a [ __ ] it's like a corpse already
yeah see I feel like it'd be I be like
can I get it anyway I think we would get
to the point be like you know how your
mouth is so you would be like hey I get
a kiss I'd be like that's how your cheek
you know you kiss yeah there's the
thief's mouth smells horrendous it does
you wouldn't be able to sleep next to me
like I couldn't sleep with my head next
to your head on the pillow oh no I feel
like bedrooms yeah
we just now just like face the other
what you know you know you face your
wall yeah I would have new smell like
beeps now I would have the Matthew why
the books all the time yeah yeah the
other person hasn't got around your
[ __ ] day yeah I can have my life I
want your lips I would be talking to
people and you I mean if they had like
my dog if I had my dog brother I have
people good foof Jesus man what you want
a mint and I'm a strong enough you
wouldn't be able to do anything I don't
like beef mint yeah I have a serious one
for you guys okay I'm serious what's
wrong
would you rather never do stand-up ever
again what up oh my god
God because I mean I plug about
comedians this is who we are
yeah at the core so like split up but
just did divorce but we can still see
each other like split up meaning you're
done on paper you're nice to each other
yeah baby [ __ ] once a year yeah
yesterday Oh how's it going how's things
going with you again you drop them up
nah it's fine
she's both the parents you guys are both
amicable I mean I would suck but I'd
have to I want our family together
oh I don't want my kid to grow up the
way I did terrible fine it's fine talked
about the boy yeah no it's not a what
it's not good yes what up but babe what
well here's the thing you make you make
a good living doing Santa you would
really have to find another I mean the
pike ass is great too but that would
really ruin your livelihood and our
livelihood and that was I like jewelry
you know what I'm saying
we are split up now I get massages and
stuff so white diamonds of course I got
it for yesterday really this for my
birthday person didn't do anything I
don't know your birthday was your summer
February it's coming no one cares about
February where do you want to go in this
bucket anyway what troops
oh yeah yeah I bet the bebut yeah I
heard at the PEI talk about your trip
watch s I wasn't covering though yeah
thank man once you say I'm thank you is
mine I bought it
thank you first oh yeah beautiful Casino
taste in jewelry is amazing
what stuff [ __ ]
man so I talked to Bart yeah Crisler
yeah and the the Rio beast yeah yeah
Bart Chrysler yeah
the what is your opinion on his weight
gains his a man I don't know I was
trying to spin this even when he took
his shirt off for that thing and weighed
himself as not obese he still looked
obese as [ __ ] you mean at the actual way
yeah January 3rd I guess that's one of
us you saw him you saw him with me a few
days ago yeah what do you think he
looked like he looked well he didn't
look like a [ __ ] workout guy right
but he said he deftly cut wait for the
weigh-in right well we both caught water
worse but like there's you put the water
back on
yeah and badly it's like his face
doesn't look much different than he did
way before yeah he's just so gross and
like we were talking Lisa on the back
yeah pushed out where it's a hard if he
lost weight you should have that foot
that fold over yeah saying a little bit
a little bit right do you feel like
because he was saying I mean I'd like to
get him back on a scale maybe I will
throwing uh is he going to skank fest I
don't know where he's going he's he's on
the road a lot yeah if you if you were
to describe said that he was really
upset what that people were saying he
gained the weight back yeah well he know
what he's upset about is that he came
away back right I don't know maybe and I
was like well you know he goes I haven't
no here's what he said yeah yeah it's a
lot and I go dude he goes they did tell
me he was like [ __ ] Tom I'm starting
up again better give the bleep up yeah
and people have been tweeting him really
yeah like why did you get fat again
it's good I'm on a scale ago yeah but I
don't know you saw him and at least for
our audience guy for me to tell
differencing 220 and 240 yeah you know
he's not all guy he won't understand
that but he's a tall guy he's over six
feet tall well over six feet tall well
over six one you know well into the 60s
I think he's just under six one you're
just under six feet but he's well
over six feet Mitch a liar I can't
believe I can't believe after asking for
the [ __ ] measurement when you were
well over an inch shorter than you said
you were there was no I said I was six
feet you said you were six one
I didn't say six one you saw always said
it taking on one he said he was six one
which turned out to be also not true yes
so then they had to do Ruby em eyes yes
but you guys both never ate it anyway
but that being said he is that again
sorry yes she is obese again yeah how do
you how do we know Bert we don't know we
don't know just look at him I mean it's
not doing anything that he's supposed to
be doing to lose the weight but he
managed it before I don't know how he
did it before I tell his people only
cram for tests and still Magica A's yeah
that this isn't the way it's going to
work but he does his vision is it the
Mickey Mantle jean-michele to him you
know I thought was really funny what's
that bet was the phrasing of it where
you go what was it it was a suitable you
see let's just get out of over here
that's all you ever do just don't be oh
be be overweight be overweight yeah
totally medically on fees and by the way
relax the lamb so fun of faith and
either of us was also here to do that
don't you do it now the I owe you both
do it no way yeah it's like if you
really did have a good work out of it
yeah for sure but I didn't think I don't
like it
can I ask you one thing it's so dumb and
it's like such a minor dumb question but
I've been thinking about it there was a
time during their weigh-ins where Joe
called you and you were abroad and he
kept calling you and calling you and
like you know I was I was a I was out
with tomatoes in New York for eating
trust Oreo I left the next day why did
you not just answer the phone like you
kept answer and then you'd hang up
because of this because I have the new
feature my phone just boosted lightly
the answer in my pocket oh this whole
time I'm like why would I do that I
don't know why you would do that to
somebody why left was the first way and
I waited so I guess midway through the
second pocket that's when I left so
weird
yeah that's all it was then when I
finally thought oh what I was kind of
drunk with the guys okay oh no like what
a jerk why always pay on the phone yeah
with the two is like let me show you the
way in
numbers like wait I need to know what
the BMI is like what do they have to be
the way Motown wrote I got word that
that we were basically whatever add
vernier you like [ __ ] like did you do a
little bit also fun but okay I'm all
about competition yeah I'm like I want
the exact measurement yeah it's like
they easily did it I'm like man cuz slow
down slow down
yeah we do have we had a waitress you do
not it by by the way after your new
weight your new height yeah five
something I'm blue unbelievable okay
yeah you were Oh point one five of an
inch above obese if you were at point
one five point one five if you are over
five eleven point seven instead of five
eleven point eight five you would abuse
yeah so for the next day it's like hey
man if he gains a pound back yeah yeah I
win the bet so I'll say like let me see
the [ __ ] competition oh my god I've
never shirked on a goddamn single bet my
life so what are we gonna do now what
should we do let's do something August
aw man I'm free I have a pretty busy
fall that's my let me ask you a question
what what about in November me and and
Burt will be in New Orleans go on that
jocose crews will be launching from
there yeah so maybe something is
November football season I say it it is
like a fun um nobody really you know
what would be really fun we have to put
it off obviously a little bit yeah would
be in probably end of January
yeah I don't even know where it is like
a look it up the national championship
game that'd be fun to go to basketball
know what we call it football football
yeah that'd be good you're a huge house
football fan yeah okay that's always on
a Monday end of all right yes that's
great yeah okay let's do it we could do
that it was your jam at FSU there's no
chance make sure they do know I mean
there would be is there going to be a
preseason top top man yeah sort of the
chance yeah there's a chance but either
way because they also open the season
against Alabama
that'd be the show they'll guess there's
still get a pretty good jump up if they
win that and they stopped it all if they
win that yeah they'll be like
helicopters action yeah yeah yeah that'd
be good i I didn't I like the idea of
going to Barcelona I'll be honest to you
that was
is rooted in truth yeah I also knew how
how [ __ ] it kind of laugh but then
when it was like actually like when we
were like hey let's do it I was like
that'll be super fun super fun yeah well
he made like a big like an air baby
together I thought that he signed by
Lana or Polly because they were playing
and the games ended up being like crazy
good game oh really one of the one of
them was I think one of them well that
there was a big shocker because I guess
they had they had multiple remark you
know yeah it was 10 the paint one of the
tanks yeah so there was one big upset or
I think Paris beat Barcelona but no one
was expecting on the first one and I
think there's a game after that we're
Barcelona when he played for Barcelona
guys yeah yeah yeah wow yeah that
would've been fun
that would have been fun man but anyways
wouldn't hide by the way I had my plan
set up cuz like a Wi-Fi first class I'm
like you know what is your flight that's
fine and I was already had a set like
you're flying first class and Bert and I
are in the back yeah yeah by the way I
know they would have arrest me who would
have Burke's oh yeah he would have been
like was good for exactly what he's up
to now to be told you can't be up here
and he would been so upset to me in
coach so upset I'm [ __ ] the middle
seat I was going to get him oh God
so worst yeah we have to do will last
you a national championship day would be
pretty me look at obvious thing yeah me
see we are absolutely okay that soccer
yeah now definitely split up that would
be a cool way for sure and then I can
finally stop getting comments on all my
[ __ ] everything I posed just a common
fear well shirt yeah an upcoming game it
will be played in Atlanta Atlanta you
marry a hey can we go to the vortex and
get that peanut butter banana burger
absolutely and it's a new stadium like a
new state-of-the-art billion dollar
stadium yeah yeah yeah that could be fun
okay what is it January 31st January 8th
dinner 8:00 yes is that cold exceed way
early no no that's right they do the New
Year's Eve stuff and I do it yeah it
does snow there in Atlanta it can vary
it gets cold but not that cold not that
cool oh let me I'd like to walk track
yeah yeah you guys you want to go do
that yeah that could be a thing yeah
let's do it
I'll not schedule anything I had it done
now all right
it'll probably go for like the week the
weekend you got to go for a couple days
yeah yeah only just landing good yeah
Sammy's your game but yeah we'll go for
earless even go Sunday and then stay
Monday Tuesday Wednesday something yeah
- bandits there because we'd be like
efficient or whatever we can figure out
someone said it okay hell yeah that'd be
great okay nice right I hope I kill
myself before that so I don't actually
pay it off cheap unbelievable so I might
have to get two seats for Bert if he
keeps going at this rate that's totally
true
enormous is he though I wonder if it's
just that you know we always see him
shirtless we never see him that was my
theory by the way but windows true when
he told me he goes when he said like
everyone's saying I go way back
I go dude every place you go you don't
have a shirt on ger most people not even
like forget obese or like the average
person shirtless is it isn't like wow
you look great
you know what can I tell you but maybe a
retort to that yeah I take my shirt off
constantly yeah Manhattan anywhere I see
it I'm just shirts off for sure sun's
out guns out you know yeah and uh what I
have my shirt off especially after I got
back like oh man so 10 G lose weight
right and with him there saying did you
gain weight it's just because the
baseline product isn't good right yeah
all right so like like no same ways
before like okay no I will say that I
will say this you know I walk around all
the time shirtless yeah it's not going
to be compliments men no it's not good I
like it I read it
yeah no but like most people have the
sense
- him wonder how the night ways I want I
want to go to scale what would your
guess be if you had a guess right now I
don't know - 90 everybod I don't think
it's the way that's even I know that's
really hot man she's like is that gotta
be off by like 10 pounds I don't know
man it got to be like 78 to 80
my inks out is that real so really every
day the way back he's not above 240 yeah
but but he waited it I think 220 yeah
no 222 you had to 219 the well the the
final day I was 216 in here Lu 220 I
think yeah yeah I would have loved that
she didn't read to the BMI and rather
have to go [ __ ] the boost the boozing
demographic oh yeah that's really hard
cause you lose weight and drink whenever
I see a woman especially the comedy
scene and suddenly it's like when I
would seen them in six months and it's
like hey you look great like what are
you doing
it's 90 percent of time doctor stop
drinking absolutely what's the one thing
you can't you can't do both man you
can't lose weight and I was off I was
gaining weight when I was traveling for
the first like about month uh-huh and I
was like my getting pudgy ER just in
making sense I'm eating like no
processed foods
I'm activist [ __ ] yeah and my friends
like it's Chang white drinking beers
here too in here is really awesome yeah
he's like 20 ounces for like a dollar up
he is a psycho though where he will go
you know see if you if you go on his
like Instagram it's like every night
he's late I got a bar with are you for
TPP have I been up and the next day it
goes any runs he does yeah so he negates
the damage he does that self regulating
thing weighs like I'm bleeding - no put
your ankle before I do the five miles
yeah great you can't exercise your liver
though yeah yeah no some two years now
Oh God he's so great yeah it's a good
car I got at least know we shot a living
memorial for him living funeral Oh sex
we can really feel his friends come out
yeah we should have you to do this
before his heart attack what what arable
but like how to live more in Atlanta but
booking for a show I'm going to do this
show and then when he shows up just have
like the big photo all right yeah hours
already don't have all right we'll be
great and have people just have fun work
music playing yeah the intervention is
that it yeah he would be like you know
this a real poor bummer to be so upset
yes run it about bar gonna miss you yeah
it's too real loads too close yeah a
reality did you ever have like a
a rule office corporate job yeah yeah
templates up to the Health Network you
guys are like cool all burn stuff
getting to know each other no look at
the people fairly topic oh man
[Music]
everybody's doing this why all the
roller
oh well guy wrote in that he had he had
two money's and he wrote in that he was
like my name is Kevin yeah and I killed
a man and he really did old things stuck
because he was in Afghanistan yeah but
his like the first thing that came to
mind was I killed a man he says looks
big for him at what and but like
everyone stop like me bro yeah we got
through the Arts yeah somebody Hank sent
a boo yeah I knew one of these and now
what is Shibuya [ __ ] some white
people [ __ ] I hope you flip
oh my god I mean it's like gene you're
going to be a cashier window yeah Wow
thanks for the [ __ ] endorsement an
old dad outfit by the way we both had
jeans tucked in yeah and two shirt and
the Denver shoes those Denver rugged
sneaks whoa see people wearing really
good look awesome
yeah man was my dog
what is NEX I have thousand of of
something oh yeah yeah all right
a black man this guy they've all my dad
jeans on look at his dork here when his
wife sneakers in dad Jean do you think
the one next to that guy up to his right
sadaqa yeah no dad I don't know the girl
well the lady yeah do you think uh ding
she's like the office like [ __ ] yeah
she's a hot girl people of hooked up
with our drama oh yeah there's always so
awful
look at his heart oh my god first I kill
myself with so - I think you should go
we and then you get here that's right he
did manage to make a verse it's that
held the it did good Kate and everything
yeah yeah sure something really
different you know it's a bummer like
this is another marketing songs from a
convention for fricking them showing you
things you like an engagement photos
from my life my cat my kids some bacon
you'll see my son Swedish - oh wow you
got me through my mouth so great boys
laugh I miss that it's better if you're
okay with me
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow I get my cat my kids someday social
that guy does not have a though he wrote
it he wrote a song oh really yeah Milli
Vanilli oh sure yeah now the bummer I
was going to say about that Walmart one
yeah it's like look you take a job at
Walmart at least I would for the chill
factor like no not a lot of heavy
responsibility you clock in you clock
out you don't have no one [ __ ]
watching you and then to have to suffer
through that corporate nonsense it takes
the whole fun out of working there in
the first place I would love to that
point I would love to see the end of
that video where he's like whatever
clapping somebody goes hey man I quit
yeah put your name tag down and walk out
yeah the guy that goes like I want seen
these [ __ ] songs
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's enough to
work here place that up yeah with that
song over his like dude I won't do this
Ronnie guy manager you don't think you
do i what
oh okay so he was like a really
enthusiastic thing I'm going to be a
cashier one day all right he was a bit
better in terms of like letting you know
cuz it should have been it was the real
fun it should be like two more verses
yes so he let me know with the hand up
but this song is over he did a way
better job in The Groundlings ooh yeah
it's like I ending something true he
knew there was a there was a time limit
yeah
[Music]
why does that go together that was
really good intuitive later thank you
very that is a two of them later so much
so why would he not know it does not
sound good on that yeah social not very
I'm trying
I had a I used to work at a company
called world link that sold airtime for
infomercials it was really bad
nine-to-five and I remember they used to
just have us come in and quarterly
meetings and then they would go over the
earnings and then we'd have to clap at
the earnings and you'd like it but I'm
making five dollars an hour late I'm
clapping for this [ __ ] CEO sixty-eight
million in products that's awesome man
hahahahaha the guy's great but they
didn't have the demeaning shibuya and
session yeah shibuya we had ice burgers
that was like in like dorm jobs well
right
Auto Show I hate situations where they
go we're gonna go around the room and
say your name and then I bet in
post-production like where you get the
whole together and I go around you like
Tom post coordinator hi and I'm like and
what was your favorite thing to it's
really just unduly punishes the
introverts I had an acting class in
college and we had to go around doing
the same thing you split up into twos
and then do something interesting about
yourself where you're from and then you
report on the other person so I was like
to the person the woman during me I was
like I don't so I'm just gonna make
something up like I don't sure whatever
so I said that I wanted to price is
right and I bid $1 and then they were
still one got to go and he bid $2 and he
ended up winning and there were two
football players in the class yeah it
was an easy a and so the lady said
interviewed me I was like okay re is
once on The Price is Right he bid one
dollar and then the guy outside the $2
and one and the full of players like man
[ __ ] because me about my bookie know
I was how to do you know last trying to
do oh my gosh like well I'm inspect but
the rules would you shouldn't be doing
$1 with a so people if they go yeah Wow
he was so worked up for me like I yeah
well soundly yeah
I'm gonna trigger something that day me
I could sing too
oh yeah Hitler pain why am i acting
class
you got something lips so remember caper
the guy that did your mom's house song I
don't got a lot of songs but he did like
like an actual real song about he did
another one maybe shot like a video oh
my god let's see it so this is it's all
going back to your house and when you
reach out into the main mommy we did
Franklin Thompson calm that was rich
calm mom's house podcast calm click your
mouse amazon.com bags if your mom's
house go back if your mom's house go
back to your mom's house I'm going
through your bomb combat drills that go
to all the of the lingo Mexico
throughout name what's you pro now I'm
just active now sexually I'm to the
class in China he got damaged they call
me duct tape oh my non-binary call play
on the track like to go watch you don't
think that can't barking I use the
bathroom that your mom's had to hold my
nose I thought I had to take a [ __ ] put
on
hold up I got something to say yes mom I
really was just like the day hey gene
show me how to big fish haha run it [ __ ]
like my Bristol stool chart on seven
diamonds on the trevor stuff you push
you over you denim I met your mama dip's
to know wouldn't a handicap stall this
was champion if I had and becoming my
boss I'm going to round town back to
your mom's house go back to you my man
going back to your mom's house I'm going
to it or no I like to have in common
laughing all the time I like that -
Larry miles out go back to your mom's
house Jeannie rocking the bottle of
peaches mother knew and believed I'll
call you from the potty - been talking
[ __ ] we'll listen to mommy music cool
stuff take a bath green water natural
like no come no one says you know what I
mean my dad go to soften the energy mr.
blocker girls had the better love life I
got a bad bike she never on and come
strike we [ __ ] at the modern-day poppy
and Trish I'm a couple of Triple D stuff
stone cows and ever want to know my
pronouns donde me I said I got a
question wanna ask talk when she read
would be [ __ ] get tricked by your
grandpa there you go Wow go back to you
my love going back is amazing
great I'm going through your
um thank you mom's house go back to your
mom's house go back to your mom's house
the whistles are level slow the window
caper that was amazing that was amazing
that reads ahead of time he did like the
good Amazon link and fun yeah
what idea you wrote us a note taking a
[ __ ] wrote a little song made a video
hope you liked it had a blast recording
filming writing editing it I hope it
makes it on the show I left the third
verse open for the mommy rappers to rap
on I love you have any questions
keep those jeans high and tight thanks
for less but it's bad again that's the
new mantra burning fat again that's
gonna be the next meme thank you so much
paper that would really make it last
name said again yeah prophetic and
prophetic and whoa hey Ari I have a
question for you do you know how when
you go to fart but you [ __ ] and it's
called a shark but what about when you
go to take a [ __ ] and you only fart
what's that called not fit fit that's a
good one we have under a mountain so
what a thump apart dump yeah no son
that's what happened you guys a lot
attachment do you wanna have there's new
submissions Oh in here because there is
no I like in poster or Sharklets by the
way somebody said this is a new one are
you ready for this someone said if you
feel this [ __ ] but only fart you had
yourself a fit someone says it ray
person says it's de Jean poo
we call it a McConaughey due to failure
to launch oh Allah and this one's great
gyro try areia favourite really I think
it's try areia a few weeks of submission
yes try a real area
I like impostor charlatans and try areia
and posters really funny god yeah water
ball huh little water bowl for know you
got a gave yourself a dog I really won't
really like how can do I go the road oh
you you believe you don't don't send
them to a kennel I have a guy on the
east side
do you live oh but you're in New York
exclusively now yeah there's people that
you can take into its normal yeah well
we'll talk part mistress concept for you
Oh number because you're going to do so
here's the thing we're talking about is
that I should be I should have been
doing fart videos when we were poor in
2008 like I easily could have done it
and I was thinking of four videos yeah
fart mistress calm Oh like this like is
hard to find sorry porn you just fart
like feeling good lady easy tonight yeah
[Music]
like $300 right there thank you
what do you mean put it on our on a
website hey webcam stuff yeah money for
nothing checks for free yeah I'd do that
anyway Wow
I mean I Wow yeah it's a great way to
earn extra code I'm saying and I guys
want to see girls do it with anywhere in
any way at home I have the perfect
scenario for make to make you for your
public queen a stripper debut you might
find the longest escalator or moving
sidewalk I can I try to go the whole way
I think if they're saying go far past
people to get their reaction yes I did
this before at Disney World and for
man-ho Florida to several groups of
unsuspecting mommies I would pay to
watch this oh my god farts shame and
disgust
all the making of Rose retirement you do
the math one by mommy thanks gene Ethan
fart the fart mistress will consider the
submission yeah yeah I farted check out
of at Rio Rio I'm sorry here we go oh
yeah you like to read
uh-huh yeah
she's looking at irregular she should've
kept raising right yeah I would've been
funnier exposing millions no the next
sentence in the [ __ ] story yeah yeah
like a monster
see this is easy-peasy it is easy money
not by when you do it you should do it
well it's such a weird vegetable though
right it's supposed to be better [ __ ] I
think you guys are onto something with
my spark Metris idea a couple ideas
ahead side when I say fart mistress Ford
he gets pulled over and has to fart her
way out of it we should write some fart
fart like like long-form fart mistress
pregnant or just gassy a trip to the
doctor and fart mistress meets Bigfoot
you'll never guess what happens next
thanks for the taking the time to read
this I wish you luck in your fart
misters endeavors best regards the butt
plug connoisseur thank you
hey have you ever got my colonoscopy no
opposed to ya
and so I got one too look at those
[ __ ] hemorrhoids yeah they blow air
into your rectum so it's like wide open
and then I look at whatever they got a
look at and then afterwards you just
full of air and so you feel like at the
ship you don't and then you fart for
about two straight days really I'm just
farting out air but crazy fart raise you
should charge for your next one and have
like a live feed of that fart and people
can pay to watch not about it like a lie
let's go na actually right from there
and it was like I had to lie on the
ground just fart the whole time oh you
capitalized yeah oh thank god okay uh
mention some of you guys yeah sure that
I have drank a full glass of water and
this full bottle of Fiji and you guys
have not even come close
well but when you hydrate constantly I
mean I had that and is coffee nothing
I peed already so like another one you
go anyway Clarissa
done whatever has done been done for a
minute
okay was the current champion yeah I am
oh really
please I'm also the observation champ
but that's another thing we'll go into
later we're going to do we're going to
wrap this up no just let people know
again the special coming out double
negative children and adulthood on
Netflix July July 1 8 sly 180 left hi
then are you working on are you already
working on building your next day yeah
I'll get my next specials gonna be all
about Judaism I decided oh really
yeah I'm gonna truly try to like flush
that out and exercise it are you going
to do it like in a Colin way where it's
like a almost like one-man show yeah I'm
going to look at it I mean I got to a
couple years in Edinboro so I really
sort of like been influenced by this one
man was like see and type shows yeah but
I work out of clubs and like make it
like funny like American stand-up yeah
they're really good at all you want but
like yeah Colin be a good one
the way Neal Brennan did three mics
interesting yeah I'll watch a lot of
stuff like that and see how I'll figure
out a mixture between like stories laws
and like tradition great exciting
awesome and foreign to that yeah I got
about like 20 now it's pretty shitty
early on but I mean put it's fun it was
hard and you know it'll get to it yeah
what's the name of the new special say
it again double- double negative and
it's a double feature yeah yeah it's a
double feature it's like a double album
yeah will it play as one little plays to
one stops the next we'll just like
automatically start playing I was like a
new episode yeah it's forward if you
just watch one and then leave the 45 and
45 so they're like manageable at that
time Mart to do not 60 60 yeah smart I
think so yeah also too hard to get a
crowd to like really be in for an hour
yeah yeah talk about this for not for
two hours I mean you guys a lot yeah for
Comi yeah yeah and then if you don't
play it on Netflix when you come back
like you want to resume playing you know
just like any stop watching house of
cards to zoom that you want to resume
our ship is double negative I would show
house of cards I'm gonna hurt event kids
all right why the park sorry are you
into the new season I stopped the first
year oh you did good over I'm talking to
me
just claim like I really enjoy it
yeah no it was good when I watched it I
actually like to I just were God we can
try like seven episodes and Cass in
total no no I was the new decision yeah
alright we got to go
thank you guys for listening the show
thanks for having me you guys got a lot
going on here long time houses ago or
something a long life yeah I think I was
on this podcast in three different
places
oh yeah apartment that's right all right
your your beach house oh yeah yeah
Redondo and uh yeah no and Silver Lake
maybe saloon no you are on I think was
in the Silver Lake house and we had a
Theo pian food wafting through because
our neighbor was we shared walls right
now at a place right yeah yeah yeah I
was about to get a tracker on the back
it's fine it was a good time all right
all times are good times are you gonna
be on the road at all or no you just Joe
nah I'll be in Montreal no I'll be in my
show Benassi Joe I'm hosting that show
okay Jay Robert Kelly Godfrey Jimmy Carr
it's a good show yeah it's a guerrilla
good show yamaneika sweet all right I'll
see you guys thanks for listening yeah
but love no I love you mommy so thanks
[Music]
talking to your car but it's totally a
car that is valid talking real car
[Music]
are you talking real fire it at five